okay it's uh 10 a.m so uh I think I'll
uh oh oh yeah I believe it's 10 AM uh
I'll go ahead and convene this beginning
of the election law committee I'll take
a piece from the former chairman Griffin
welcome to election law
um today we're going to be opening the
public hearing to
hb115 relative to changing oh I'm sorry
Pledge of Allegiance I apologize we'll
I pledge allegiance
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
foreign First Act I already forgot
something not bad coming out of the gate
swinging
um all right so now we will open the
hearing to hb115 relative to changing
the date of the state primary I'll
recognize the Bill's sponsor
representative Joseph Sweeney
thank you uh thank you acting chairman
Barry and members of the House election
law committee uh I am proud to introduce
House Bill 115 relative to changing the
date of the state primary election this
bill moves the state primary election to
the second Tuesday in June the house
supported a June primary bill in 2021
and in 2022 when finalizing the second
Tuesday in June we meaning myself in the
sponsorship team wanted to make the
primary as late as desirable for the
sponsorship team while still ensuring it
would be far earlier than our current
September primary September primaries
support the incumbent elected official
in whatever office that they hold it'll
only allows for a seven-week general
election period that detracts from the
ability of freshly minted party nominees
and Challengers to campaign in a general
election environment and a growing
consensus of both Republicans and
Democrats are in agreement that
September primaries are just too late
for the process of the general election
to start months deep into the summer
months deep in the summer for vacation
should be avoided as well if only to
ensure the highest level of voter
engagement and attention is paid towards
the primary election July and August to
me are out of the question for such a
primary election as Granite Staters are
out of state and spending time with
their families and shouldn't be bothered
with Party politics a June primary
allows for granite Staters to focus on
the preceding two months in April and
May while voting in June this would
allow then both parties and their
nominees the opportunity to organize and
unite over the course of the summer
months and really get into gear right as
Labor Day weekend kicks off into the
general election Sprint of the fall this
will allow the campaigns to communicate
with granite Staters at large right
after Labor Day when folks really do
start to pay attention in Earnest
towards our elections we in state
government should always be looking for
practical solutions that make our
current processes and systems more
efficient and pragmatic holding our
state primary on the second Tuesday in
June does that and I asked the committee
for their support of this important
legislation thank you and I'll take any
questions
well that was unexpected saying no
questions um thank you representative
Sweeney thank you very much
next up uh we're going to have the
representative from the Secretary of
State's office a senior deputy secretary
of state uh Patricia Lovejoy
I'm sorry thank you chairman uh I just
wanted to present where the Secretary of
State's office sits on this bill
our preference would be to move the
election a couple of weeks earlier than
what it is right now right now
there's a there's always an issue of
trying to get the yukava ballots out on
time and the last um election cycle we
added post-election audits that happened
and immediately after the election so
there's a lot going on
um in a very short period of time so our
preference would be to move it forward a
few weeks
but that being said if the decision is
to move it to June we will obviously be
there to support and make sure that the
election is is done well in June that's
all
uh yes representative Baum
thank you Mr chairman thank you question
aren't there at least 12 other states
having their Primary in August
I do not know the exact number I know
Massachusetts is just about at that same
time
um a couple weeks before ours
and I don't know how many other states
are
further questions from the committee
well look at this we're moving fast
today seeing none thank you Deputy
senior Deputy Lovejoy
thank you very much Mr chair
um
and uh
actually you're a co-sponsor the bills
so it's I guess the rules do allow you
to be the chair you just can't uh
question or participate in the
questioning is that correct yeah I'm not
familiar but I have no intention of
asking questions so good okay well
your questions are good if uh when the
when you ask them but anyway so I'm
opposed to uh I I submitted a written
testimony to the website against both
these bills and I'm much more and um
I almost thought you were uh introducing
HB 333 to have a proposal that everyone
was really going to hate and then
somehow this one wouldn't seem as bad
but I think it's still a bad idea
I think
it's notwithstanding what uh the members
said to Manchester I feel exactly the
opposite I think the late primary is
useful for incumbents it gives them uh
more time to prepare a campaign more
time to make a case and I can speak from
personal experience because I had a
I had a gentleman uh jumping into the
race
here in Stratford District 10. I'm
representative Tim Horrigan from
Stratford tens which is the town of
Durham so one of my neighbors jumped at
the races June ran a very good campaign
and
um
I only beat him by four votes in the
recount so I think that would have been
much less likely to happen if he'd had
to make the decision if he'd had too
fewer months to make to this decision
back in April um and um
and also like you didn't have all summer
both of us didn't have all summer to
like ramp up our campaign even as it is
um it feels like we're campaigning the
whole time and both of these bills will
make that uh much worse um so I I think
a later primary is actually beneficial
to incumbents what the member from
Manchester may have met is that
democratic incumbents
except for the governors uh for races
the top particular races below the
governor have done very very well in the
last several Cycles um but I don't think
that's a function of the primary date I
think that's a function of the quality
of candidates who've made it through the
Republican primary process they just
weren't um
they just weren't as strong in the
opinion of the uh electorate as the as
the Democrats and I don't I think if
anything that incumbency advantage would
be
um even even worse with an earlier
primary
um
also the current calendar is very good
for uh candidates who are members of the
legislature because uh the filing window
was right about right not is right
around the end of the uh end of the
session so that's a good time for us to
decide
what we want to do going forward and
that applies not just to uh those
wrestling running for election but also
that those of us who move up to the
senate or even those of us who want to
run for top of the ticket offices for
example uh
Senate uh Senate president president
Morris the former Senator president uh
ran for con uh ran for Congress and fell
fell a little short but I think it would
have been harder for him to make that uh
decision
um if he'd still been in the middle of
being the Senate President so and he ran
for the U.S Senate I'm sorry if these uh
so I think
so I think I think just a fair thing to
do is to keep the calendar more or less
the way it is um as for an August
primary I've actually submitted bills in
the past for the August primary
and it didn't get very far but the idea
has a lot of Merit and this bill could
possibly use as a vehicle for that um I
know
um
I think Massachusetts still has a
September primary I know specifically
uh Vermont has a mid-august primary and
New York State's primary was August 23rd
and I know that because I was a looking
at the situation with George Santos
because one of the things with primary
dates a longer primary and he actually
his primaries on August 23rd so he
actually had a late summer primary and
still felt and you know still you know
fell through the cracks but the later
primary does give us more time to weed
out you know extremely bad
um candidates such as him while giving
uh
well giving like Insurgent candidates
more time to prepare their race like the
gentleman who nearly beat me in Durham
and or to name another example my
neighbor Bruce Fenton who ran for the
U.S Senate and was totally unknown but
he um
did manage you know he did manage to at
least uh you know get on the radar or
get in the debates and that probably
also would not have been the case if
he'd had to like uh file like way back
in uh March as this bill proposes or
even earlier is the other one so I think
um I think we should leave it more
though more or less the way it is if you
want to move the primary up to late
August which is not really a problem uh
these schools are already uh schools
already open in August the families
maybe Governor sununa family spends the
entire uh Summer from Memorial Day
through Labor Day at the lake or
whatever but most families uh you know
most families take only relatively brief
vacations during the summer and most of
them are probably back in their uh
fall routines by late August so
for so I urge you uh urge you certainly
not to pass this bill
unless you want to actually extend
unless you actually want to have an
August primaries otherwise a June
primary it's not as ridiculous as the
other idea that I'll be talking about in
a few minutes but it's still a bad idea
so I'd be happy to take any questions
thanks are there any questions from the
committee representative Howard sorry
everybody has to be patient with me I'm
learning new name so representative
Howard thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Horgan being a
representative from Durham uh what
percentage of your voters are students
if you know
that um
it's uh well about half of the names in
the checklist are are student student
voters and that's actually
um
one thing with the the current
current primary I think is a good thing
is that the uh
this also affects when people uh have to
declare they have to can register for
voting and declare their party
affiliation right now that fits in
pretty well with the student calendar
because they're showing up in August and
actually an earlier primary might be
problematic from that standpoint but uh
but uh yeah so it's uh they they vote
they haven't actually been starting to
vote with more numbers than the primary
and recent recent years so that's uh
they've been I think the later
generation of the students um including
yourself although your father is also
State Rep candidates here from a
political family but I think young
people are more and more recognizing
that it's not just the general election
that the primaries are also important
and are participating so
are there any other questions from the
committee
seeing none uh thank you representative
Morgan
and uh with that are there anyone else
who wish to speak uh on House Bill 115.
it's
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 115 and I
will we will recess until the public
notice of 10 45 for House Bill 333
relative to changing the primary date of
the state primary election and adding a
runoff election if necessary so we'll be
yeah
foreign
okay
um it's 10 45 I'm gonna hold on opening
the hearing back up because we don't
have our committee assessment again I
don't know if we're being live streamed
yet so if the committee will indulge me
and we'll go find our assistant make
sure that the good people watching at
home can get their Youtube footage so
I'm gonna go figure out what's going on
never mind representative representative
Howard has informed me we are streaming
so I will I will now open up the hearing
uh on HB 333 fiscal note relative to
changing the date of the state primary
election and adding a runoff election if
necessary I'll recognize the Bill's
sponsor a representative Joe Sweeney of
man Salem uh excuse me uh representative
Sweeney you are recognized welcome to
election law thank you very much acting
chairman Barry and the members of the
health selection law committee I will
actually be very brief and quick on this
bill HB 333 I am proud to introduce it
today and I'm sure we will hear from my
good friend the member from Somersworth
later on this bill as well however I am
asking the committee to retain this
legislation the legislation would set up
a primary election on town meeting day
in March and then if candidates for U.S
Senate Congress in in the governor's
office do not reach 50 percent of their
primary vote for the nomination a runoff
would be had uh between the top two
finishers so that a candidate would get
50 percent there are a number of bills
that deal with this sort of similar sort
of vein of thinking of trying to get the
candidates that are nominated by a party
to be uh 50 plus support from the party
uh different bills with different policy
recommendations whether they be runoff
elections approval voting rank Choice
voting for this bill I would I would
just ask the committee to retain it so
that we can continue studying it I think
we'll see other pieces of legislation
that deal with it and I don't want to
prematurely have the house take a
position on the policy without a
retention committee subcommittee which
I'm happy to serve as a non-member of
election law on uh but that is that is
my hope today is that when you guys do
exact this uh this Bill gets retained
but I am happy to take any questions on
the underlying policy
are there any questions from the
committee
uh yes representative Lane thank you Mr
chair uh representative Sweeney do you
have a preferred alternative to your
bill like you mentioned ranked Choice
voting are there other things that you
would prefer in lieu of this uh thank
you for the question uh not without
studying all varying options and seeing
really what is the best system that
other states employ to get nominees from
parties that the majority plus of a
party support so I'm not willing to
commit today to what else I would
support but I'm open to have the
conversation as legislation should be
other questions from the committee
representative qualey
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Sweeney for talking with
us today
uh
looking at at the bill on
page two down near the bottom line
25 if you say that
the candidate shall file with the
appropriate official between the first
Wednesday in March is that a typo
that is a typo and it's a further reason
for the retention uh this bill was with
the OLS
um situation that we dealt with
um this Bill had two I I wanted to get
two redrafts and I was only able to get
one redraft in um the original version
uh had those mistakes in it as well as
it applied to every candidate which was
not my intent imagine a state
representative race uh going to a runoff
would be a headache for many
um so there are other changes to the
bill that I do want to pursue but with
the situation with OLS and redrafting
and just the start of the of the
legislative session so far with the
addition of this having a fiscal note so
it would have to be acted on early is
why I'm just asking almost retention so
that we can extend the conversation and
and the work on this process and Bill
one more follow-up yes I'd like a
follow-up please thank you
you mentioned just now in your testimony
about trying to coordinate the this
Primary in March with a town meeting day
but not all towns have their meeting so
there's that another issue you'd like to
look at further the resolve absolutely
and I will say as the starting point of
the of the policy in the conversation we
felt you know town meeting day would be
the earliest we could have our state
primary and it's actually a little nod
to our presidential primary which
started on town meeting day over 100
years ago when every town essentially
had town meeting day elections they
didn't want to open up the town hall
twice in the the winter for our
presidential primary and then we
switched it so it's always just one week
before but the actual date for
presidential primary in statute is town
meeting day unless another state tries
to go ahead of us and then we do it a
week before so that's just kind of the
base point of really we talk about
moving the primary up earlier and
earlier I would say March is as a big
supporter of moving the primary up I'd
say the second Tuesday in March is the
earliest I'm willing to go for the state
primary and really just wanted to and
with a runoff system that having a
runoff off later in May
but it really is just a conversation
starter not a you know this is the only
acceptable time I would have for it okay
thank you thank you other questions from
the committee
okay seeing none thank you
representative Sweeney I believe that's
the last we'll hear from you today enjoy
your ride back to Manchester thank you
uh next up is uh oh Salem excuse me uh
next up is senior deputy secretary of
state uh Lovejoy uh
senior Deputy Lovejoy welcome to
thank you Mr chair
um again my name is Patricia Lovejoy I
am the senior deputy secretary of state
um I've seen here representing Secretary
of State we are opposed to this bill we
have several reasons that we are opposed
to the bill
um the first regarding the date in March
um
we believe that doubling up with
Municipal and state elections
would create a lot of a lot of problems
I think that your local issues somebody
running for school board or you have a
town that's trying to do
a new police station a fire station
Library whatever it is that those local
issues will get drowned out in a primary
you have the primary for U.S Senate for
congress for governor those issues will
basically suck all the auction oxygen
out of the room I don't we don't think
it's fair for the local issues to be
caught up at the same time as the
primaries
also
um
your the number of ballots that somebody
may be having to vote on currently in
like my town in March you get three
ballots you get one for your local
school district then we're part of a
Cooperative school district and our town
ballot now you'll be adding
um a fourth ballot
in in some Village districts you could
be talking as many as five ballots
also we have we have concerns regarding
um people receiving their absentee
ballots the you will call the rules of
needing to get ballots out 45 days ahead
of time does not apply to Municipal
elections
so the yukava ballots would be going out
45 days ahead of time we also get the
absentee ballots to the towns shortly
after that so you could have a town
having its primary ballots going out say
40 days
35 40 40 days before the election
your town ballots
would go out generally later we had
issues last year
um where several of the school districts
did not have their ballots to the towns
when the towns were ready to send out
their absentee ballots so then the town
sent out their Town their Municipal
level election
absentee ballots and then when they got
the ones from the school districts then
they sent those out so you could be
looking at a possibility of Voters
receiving absentee ballots in three
different mailings which I think could
be very confusing
we also believe
in the the issue about a runoff is is
one that concerns us in our constitution
uh in article two I think it's um
sections 33 34 and 42. they all refer to
elections being decided by a plurality
of votes and in 1912 there was an
amendment that specifically changed the
language from a majority of votes to a
plurality of votes so we believe that
there is a constitutional issue with
this runoff this is something that you
will hear me saying this afternoon when
we were when we do ranked Choice voting
um you know as a general rule the
Secretary of State's office is opposed
to any legislation where we would not
know the outcome of election on Election
night
and one other little wrinkle on this one
is the state runs any state level
election so the primaries are run by the
Secretary of State's office
and the municipalities are responsible
for the local elections so you have a
you know a possibility of having two
different authorities running these
elections
so those are the basic reasons why we uh
oppose this bill I'd be willing to take
any questions
from the committee
yes representative Lane
thank you Mr chair um thank you um Miss
Lovejoy
um
you mentioned it and I just want to make
sure I heard you right you were that you
would be opposed to any change that
would delay the results Beyond election
night did I hear that correctly yes
could you explain follow-up follow-up of
course could you explain why uh
we we have a real history here in New
Hampshire of always having those um
election results available uh when you
are talking about a runoff election and
it is
um you're going to end up with those
ballots all having to come to Concord to
be able to appropriately do a runoff a
runoff election if you're talking at the
U.S Senate Governor you name it level
um it will the delay in finding out
who is is elected will take or who's
going to be on the ballot will take
quite a while and if you're looking at a
presidential primary I can't remember if
this bill specifically I know when the
afternoon ones specifically talks about
presidential election uh not knowing the
results of New Hampshire's first in the
nation
presidential primary on Election night
would I think be a pretty significant
issue for the state
you have a follow-up sibling you know so
any other questions from the committee
yes representative Muirhead thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um on the on the matter of plurality and
majority
um I understand from your testimony the
Secretary of State's office
believes it would be unconstitutional
for the legislature to require a
majority even though a majority is also
a plurality
um has the Secretary of State's office
received a legal opinion to that effect
or is it just the legal Judgment of the
office
we are just stating that we believe
there may be a constitutional issue
uh because the Constitution was
specifically changed in 1912 to go from
a majority to a plurality we believe
that this is an issue that needs to be
taken into consideration in any bills
regarding runoffs we are not making we
are not stating a legal opinion we just
believe that there is a constitutional
issue follow-up
sorry just to confirm the Secretary of
State's office has not consulted with uh
with a with the attorney general or with
a law firm about this it's just the so
there's no legal analysis behind this is
that correct correct we believe that
there's our reading is that there may be
a constitutional issue we think this is
something that the legislature needs to
further further investigate we wanted to
bring up the issue
further questions from the committee
um I do have
um two questions I am it's further
disclosure I am a sponsor on this bill
um so if I step out of line I think
representative lingle give me uh well
let me know but I don't think I'm going
to
um you raised in your testimony um you
didn't want Municipal elections to be
drowned out by state issues
um uh couldn't the same argument be made
of we hold our state elections and our
federal elections at the same time so we
don't want our state issues to be
oh that's a valid point but we are
concerned about the local elections they
just have a much smaller
um
geographic area that they are dealing
with and in a town who's trying if
you've ever been involved in an issue in
your town where you're trying to get
whether it's a new library I mean
several towns it takes some multiple
elections and to have that issue drowned
out by
primaries for U.S Senate Congress we
don't think it's fair for those local
local issues I'll save my debate for
that uh for the executive session
because I don't want to get in the back
and forth I do have one more
um this is just more of a point of
intrigue than necessarily the bill
it stems from the municipal and state
kind of vein representative Sweeney said
that our state law says that the First
Nation primary will fall on the
municipal town meeting day
um if it's not if we're not a week in
front of everybody that's what he says
the default you said that the Municipal
elections are run by the municipality
and state and federal run by the state
so how would the Secretary of State's
office uh do that if if we did if for
some reason every other state decided to
stop jumping in front of us how would we
I would have to get back to you on that
we haven't had the uh primary the
presidential primary on
um town meeting day I think for a very
long time
thank you I it was just a point of
curiosity it was this these are the
things I go through my mind in case
anybody's wondering uh any other
questions from the committee
all right seeing none thank you uh
senior Deputy a Lovejoy it's always a
pleasure uh next up is representative
that's some written testimony around
first which actually applies to both
bills but I I mostly talked about this
thank you if you could give it straight
steam the testimony is is theoretically
it's duplicative because I submitted it
through the submit testimony thing in
the website but I I'm at least in my
mind I'm totally unclear where it goes
or how anybody can actually see what's
submitted to it apparently some people
can see it but anyway so I'm resident
Timothy Horrigan I'm continue to
represent Stratford County District 10
which is the uh town of Durham
and um
I don't know whether uh
and in the previous testimony I did like
open the door I did open the door to
moving the primary forward a few weeks
but I still think it should be late
summer so I'm still like uh
I feel like maybe there's a bit of a
bait and switch going on here which is
like
myself and I'm speaking just for myself
probably some other Democrats say well
we could
maybe we need to move to primary a
little early and then they're going to
like say we're going to compromise and
move it to June which at least for me
personally is not acceptable so I'm uh
I'm probably not as smart as I think I
am but I'm not planning to fall for that
particular baited switch if that's what
happens but anyway
um actual skip ahead
skip ahead to the last issue of my
written testimony which was uh
redistricting last year's very
districting year and the legislature
didn't complete the various
participating plans to a week before the
filing window and in fact the
Congressional plan was never really
completed with the the federal court had
to draw the lines for us um
and I don't see
if what HB well I don't even see how we
can meet the March filing window and
vision in HP 115 or this December one
which is presumably what this one
envisions although there's a drafting
errors I just
I just don't see how this process can
play out that quickly especially since
from what I as you shared with me
reminded me which I guess I heard at the
time Mr chair like we're chatting out in
the hallway
um the Census Data was delayed in in
2020 2021 and that was one of the
reasons why the redistricting process
took longer
then maybe it took a long time in 2022
so anyway
um we joined the district lines way back
in so the after the 2030 census we would
be joining the district lines in
December 2031 and I don't know how
realistic that is but that's uh although
I guess we have a decade to figure that
part of it is
um if we pass HB 333 with the March
primary
um that would lengthen the post primary
phase of the campaign from roughly a
month and a half to almost eight months
are you raising your hand are you just
holding it up okay no I'm sorry I'm I'm
reading and this is how I oh thank you
oh no no problem you're doing a fine job
and better than me probably anyway so
that would
place the nominees in the awkward I'm
not sure what a nominee is supposed to
do if you have eight months until the
general election like or do you either
board the elector to death burn out
their supporters and uh you know and
everything by knocking at door spitting
of signs mainly postcards running
against putting them signs all those
things we do during the primary for
basically three quarters of the year
um actually almost the entire year
including the primaries I um
one thing I like about the current
system it compresses uh both the primary
general elections into a few weeks
basically in the late summer and early
to mid-autumn even though the candidate
recruitment process starts in the spring
and you know we we're running a little
we are running
um in the early part of the summer too
but basically the whole thing is
compressed into like you know about
uh from basically from at least for a
State Rep candidates mostly can stuff
runs from like about August 1st to uh
election day in November which is
actually I think a good thing rather
than just stretching the whole thing out
over the entire year
um
also that if we have a March primary
that guarantees the prime campaign is
going to hinge on issues which have
little or nothing to do with on the
voters months eight months later I think
in 2020 the name especially dramatic
example
the primary would have happened
basically before the pandemic and
everything that went along with it and
also uh also before the black to George
Floyd murder of the black lives matter
uh movement and so the issues are in
people's minds in November were probably
quite different from what they were you
know back in March um
and even and um and this would happen
even in 2022 I gave an example which
probably I'll skip over in order not to
start a riot but have a certain event
that was investigated this year and
I think some people's view we learned a
lot more about what happened in January
2021 than we did when this started that
may have changed some people's thinking
maybe not
and um
so that's about that's um so that's
that's basically it I think a long post
primary campaign is bad I think uh
having a
you know having the primary campaign the
winners also I didn't go into that but
that's not really a great idea I think
it's better to have it in the summer
especially for those of us who are in
the in the legislature
um because uh right now the current
primary move basically start the
re-election campaign right after the end
of the second year session and that's
perfect for us and anything else and
this would be we'd be running even
before the second year session starts
and that's bad
um
oh as for the runoffs although they're
sort of like backing off the sponsor to
Prime sponsor just backed off from that
idea that doubles the cost of the
election and also
um
and um also uh of course it's
inconsistent since there's lots of down
ticket races which are uh single seat
races I mean I see the lodge we're not
trying to have a runoff for house race
how do you decide what the cutoff is you
know that's just
um but there are most of the down even
some of the State Rep races are single
member seats but the state senate and
County Commissioners except in my County
Stratford County where we we have a
three-person at-large district so that
the uh the runoff election that doubles
the cost of the election and I'm not
sure if it's a great idea and um I'm not
sure if any of this would also improve
the quality of a
the quality of uh The Challengers and
the primaries I know certainly I'll just
speak as a Democrats and we've Governor
cenuni has beaten us you know four times
in a row and um
especially this time he did it with the
candidate who I thought at least my
opinion was a very strong candidate ran
a very good race and uh you know he's
still got uh you know he still fell more
than a little short and I guess the
situation has been reversed the opposite
way for the Republicans and the down
ticket you know the Congressional and
Senate races but I don't think
how this procedure helps helps that
problem you know that's probably just
um that's more sort of an internal
problem getting stronger candidates to
run but
which is true for the Governor's
candidates too but
so anyway I uh I mean retaining the bill
that uh sounds I mean that's obviously
an easy way out of it I would actually
probably prefer it yelling the whole
thing because I think this whole the
runoff election the early primaries I
just think those are fundamentally bad
ideas and you know the ranked Choice
voting can be considered on its own
merits but I don't think
and I think the Secretary of State's
office is right to be concerned about
the constitutionality of it especially
if in this case we're doing some races
with the runoff to guarantee the
majority we're doing other races uh
other single-seat races
was the old traditional plurality of
things so that's really inconsistent so
um those are my that's why I'm against
this bill and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you representative
Morgan is there any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you representative uh
was there anyone else who wishes to
testify on HB 333 fiscal note
all right seeing no other questions uh
great news committee members we get to
have an early and long lunch I will be
closing the hearing on
hb33fn we will be in recess until 1pm I
will ask the members of the Republican
caucus to hang back before you go over
and get your lunch so we can have a very
brief caucus
um and uh we'll see you back at one
o'clock
could I also ask the Democrats to do the
same thing uh Ross where are you going
okay
all right welcome and we are going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
foreign
thank you Mr chair and honorable members
of the committee for the record my name
is Ellen Reed I represent Newmarket and
new Fields
um
and I just as a like a preface to these
next two hearings
um so those of you who've been on the
committee before are familiar with RCV
hearings going pretty long two to three
hours also last year we had the big Bill
first what we call the big Bill where we
go into great depth on on a lot of
issues and then we had the enabling
build this year it's reversed so we're
going to try to honor the committee's
time as best as possible so there will
be some issues that we touch on in the
this enabling bill now that we might get
questions to go in depth and the the
details aren't necessarily pertinent for
the enabling bill but they are for the
big bill so we'll probably say can we
please just address that in the next
hearing
um if you all would honor that I also
have asked because in order to honor the
committee's time ask that
I have not asked people to come and
testify those who have come to side that
they wanted to testify I've asked them
to be very brief we're focusing just on
a couple of experts to really I think
those of you who've been here before
know that we can fill this room with
with supporters that's not the question
uh whether or not our CV's popular is a
concept but really to do an educational
Deep dive into the issues having said
that HB 345 is before you this is an
enabling only Bill it does nothing in
and of itself other than untie the hands
of parties and municipalities
um for Municipal elections for
municipalities it would only be for
their Municipal elections you cannot do
other elections
um with one town doing RCV another one's
not so it'd only be for the Municipal
elections every town and every party
would get to opt in through their own
internal procedures for municipalities
that means a vote of the town's people
through their normal
likely warrant process whatever process
that that town or city has currently it
would be through the normal process
as you're aware we're Dylan's rule state
which means towns cannot currently do
this until we enable them so that is why
this is necessary for towns that want to
have ranked Choice voting for their
Municipal elections and there is a very
very good reason why towns would want
that which I will touch on in a moment
four parties the party would opt in
through their own internal procedure as
normal how they do every other decision
both for municipalities and parties they
would notify the Secretary of State 90
days in advance at least 90 days in
advance
any party or municipality May opt in
independently to any other party or
municipality and they can also opt out
at any time so there's no onerous
anything nothing binding this only
inside their hands and they liberates
them to do just what they want
um it also allows both municipalities
and probably more importantly parties to
specify which Races they would like to
enable ranked Choice voting for which
again I think especially for parties
will be very important before I get into
more detail because and I don't want to
get into too much detail on the concept
of ranked Choice voting because we do
have the big Bill next but I feel like
there's so many new members of this
committee this year that I should
probably just do a very brief
um overview of why it's good what
problem is it solving and how it's done
so the way we currently vote is referred
to as first pass the post it comes from
you know Antiquity really Mary old
England uh when they didn't really have
more sophisticated ways of
um voting now the problem with first
pass the poster one of the biggest
problems is that it's fine if you have a
single winner election so one seat up
for grabs and two people running it
works great because whoever wins is
guaranteed to have 50 or more of the
vote and therefore a mandate from the
voters but if you have more than two
people running for that seat you may end
up with a winner that has what we call a
low plurality uh low plurality vote low
plurality winner and what that means is
it's possible for the other two
supporters of the other two candidates
to have combined and preferred one of
the other two to the person who won and
this ends up with a lot of division
because if someone wins with 37 percent
of the vote but the supporters of the
other two candidates feel strongly that
they're against them they feel like that
is an illegitimate election and I think
that we've all heard a lot of
um saddening stories about how bitterly
divided and polarized our society has
become because people feel like
different elections are illegitimate
and I would say that on both sides
actually
um so I want to Define very very quickly
plurality and majority because it will
come up and you'll especially come up in
the next bill I don't want to go into
detail for those of you new I presume
most people know this plurality simply
means the most number of votes majority
is 50 plus one
the majority is a type of plurality so
all majorities are pluralities not all
pluralities are majorities majorities
are a better type of plurality I will
say this much ranked Choice voting does
not require a majority to win in fact
there's plenty of times that you don't
have a majority when you have a ranked
Choice voting winner but we'll get more
into that probably in the next spill
um so again the this was known the idea
of a low plurality winner was a known
issue even back in the day and so a lot
of places including New Hampshire and a
lot of other states started to Institute
a majority rule we actually had in our
constitution from the beginning a
requirement that winners for certain
races have a majority because we wanted
to not have those low plurality winners
unfortunately what started happening
political games we're all familiar with
that parties were starting to realize
that if they ran someone who could split
the other Party's candidate then there
would be no majority in what we had in
the constitution is if there was no
majority the legislature would decide
and so increasingly so late 1800s and
1900s legislative races were being
decided by the legislature and what was
seen as very very political decisions
and so around that time we amended the
Constitution to say it just requires a
plurality but we're back to the low
with this as I've already said is it
decreases voter confidence it increases
voter apathy decreases turnout and just
in general is seen as uh not as valid a
system people don't feel like their
votes matter and indeed there are
elections where votes don't matter if
you are one party in a district that's
majority of the other party very
frequently your vote really doesn't
Mount to too much
and I think the goal we can all agree is
to have every vote count equally one
person one vote
foreign
the other option you have and some towns
do this which is why towns will want the
ability to enable ranked Choice voting
and many states do this as well is
runoff elections in a runoff election
yes you're probably familiar
um if there's no one that has a majority
all of the candidates except the top two
are eliminated and you have a whole new
election you wait a month or two turn
everybody back out it's millions of
dollars so run off elections while
they're better than low plurality
winners they are extremely expensive
um It suffers greatly from A reduced
turnout people kind of get hyped for the
general and then for One race don't
typically turn out in the same numbers
um also the procedure for runoff is
inferior to ranked Choice voting because
you're eliminating all of the candidates
now it's very very possible if you had a
slate of say six or seven candidates
that three or four of those candidates
supporters would coalesce around one but
because all of those candidates got
eliminated the voters are then forced
into one of the top two
so that's another way in which uh it's
problematic
so uh of the different systems that are
available ranked Choice voting has the
highest definition picture of the will
of the electorate it has the capacity to
not just capture who people want but the
level at which they want those
candidates and their ability to say
anyone but that guy right which is
something that our current system
um so very very quickly and we can go
into more depth with questions
especially on the next bill
um so ranked Choice voting simply if you
can rank your favorite flavors of ice
cream you can rank your favorite
politicians uh and you rank them and
then they go through runoffs so we take
everybody's first preference
if nobody has uh reached the threshold
for winning which in a single member
district is 50 plus one then you
eliminate the least vote getter and
those ballots go get counted towards
those people's next preference very very
similar to a runoff election repeat
balloting
that threshold for the single member is
50 plus one in multi-member districts
that threshold is different and the
formula is one over the number of seats
available plus one so that's one of the
reasons that not every election results
in a majority uh winner
so benefits of ranked Choice voting to
get back into
um Less in the theory and back into this
bill so on the town level enabling towns
especially runoff towns who can then
save quite a bit of money in not having
to do a runoff election which I already
mentioned not only is expensive not only
suffers from low turnout not only has an
inferior way of of eliminating
candidates but also has the problem of
extending the campaign season which
people already feel is super divisive I
don't know if you've ever talked to your
constituents but people hate campaign
signs they hate campaign season in
general and there's actually been
National moves to movements to shorten
campaign season not lengthen it so and
not only does it extend the campaign
season but then you also have the
problem of the empty seat in the
legislature which we're familiar with
now we're familiar with on the national
level as well when you have a runoff
election you have that empty seat
allowing towns to solve all of those
problems by enabling ranked Choice
voting if they so choose specifically if
the voters of that town so choose allows
us to use those towns as Laboratories of
democracy that wonderful Federalist
covered all the runoff things primaries
so for primaries I'll speak of primaries
broadly and then I want to get into the
presidential primary which is kind of
the really juicy stuff uh primaries
as we have seen in recent both
Congressional and presidential primaries
in this state frequently have uh slates
of 15 even upwards of 30 candidates and
this is when ranked Choice voting really
really shines when you have these many
candidates you have the ability
um in the first pass the post system of
having a winner that has 18 19 of the
vote clearly not a mandate clearly and
very easily Could Be Imagined is not
really supported by a majority of the
people
um ranked Choice voting really is
necessary in situations where you have
that many candidates and I'll get to in
the next bill um exactly why because we
have international examples of how bad
things can get when you have that many
candidates
um primaries in general are super
important for our democracy they're an
integral part of how we elect people I
know we they are in fact private entity
uh events however we fund them on a
state level because they're so integral
to our democracy to our representative
democracy Boss Tweed is famous for
saying I don't care who gets to vote so
long as I get to pick the candidates
that's why that's why primaries are so
very important so having more accurate
representation on the primary level is
super important
ranked Choice voting also eliminates the
need for strategic voting and this is
really I mean again the big Bill we can
go into more details but the idea that
you're forced between the the lesser of
two evils that you don't really get to
vote your conscience you'd really prefer
this guy but in a first pass the post
system there's only two candidates that
ever matter and first pass the post
that's the the person in the lead and
the person closest to kicking out the
person in the lead
those are the only two candidates that
matter we consider in electoral Theory
any vote cast for anyone other than
those two people a wasted vote because
it doesn't actually help one of the two
Front Runners
okay
now it eliminates that strategic voting
you liberates you to vote your
conscience which I think is kind of what
we all were taught like in third grade
how our democracy is supposed to work
you really vote for the person you like
best
because it never ever hurts you to rank
people after your first preference your
ballot never counts towards anybody
other than your first preference unless
your first preference gets eliminated so
you're completely liberated to vote as
your conscience dictates
it also decreases negativity in
campaigns and increases in the case of
specifically primaries as we're talking
about enabling party Unity
um it does increase turnout candidates
tend to not bad-mouth each other if
they're trying to get the supporters of
another candidate to choose them as
their second or third preference right
so it tends to decrease the the negative
campaigning people aren't as turned off
they do feel like their votes matter
because they get more of a voice on
their ballot and people turn out more
but specifically in presidential
primaries it really has the the power to
bring parties together much much sooner
we're used to hearing news about how
divided a party gets during a
presidential primary and how quickly the
party wants to try to gather the party
Unity back together
in presidential primaries and I presume
all of you are aware
you're not actually like voting you're
voting for someone to get delegates in a
convention right it's not the the
typical way of voting and so there's a
threshold so there's not a one winner
there's a threshold for getting those
delegates in the Republican party it's
10 and the Democratic party it's 15 and
what that means and I can refer you to
um the sheet that looks like this
this top left chart
shows the dash blue line is the
Democratic threshold of 15 the dashed
red line is the Republican threshold of
10 and you can kind of read it however
whichever party you would like to read
it for based on that line but just
reading it for only the Democratic party
in this example only Apple gets
delegates at all even though
nearly 85 percent of the voters wanted
someone else meaning the party
effectively throws out 85 percent of all
ballots cast in that presidential
primary
I don't think 85 percent of people
voting in a presidential primary went
um and you know there's been plenty of
talk about the lack of democratic
um
principles in in Party primary
presidential primary systems if you look
down at
um in this sheet is specifically for
first uh in the nation primary results
which I'll get to I looked on the the
ranked Choice voting results in a
primary you're no longer just
eliminating until someone gets wins like
in a normal election you're eliminating
until people everybody left is over the
threshold whether it's 10 or 15 percent
and here you get much much clearer
results
here you can see that there's a few
Front Runners that have a lot of support
whether or not they had supported other
candidates first you don't get a whole
bunch of candidates like you do in the
first graph that all have like eight
percent nine percent seven percent you
get a few strong clear Front Runners
which is the kind of information by the
way you want in a first in the nation
primary or an early primary at all you
don't want static you want clear Salient
actionable information and not just for
the rest of the voters of the country
you also want it for the candidates and
this is where we get back to party Unity
candidates in a presidential primary are
always looking to see whether or not
they should drop and win if they can see
that their supporters actually they can
get some of peers supporters over if
Peer gets eliminated they can get some
orange supporters if orange gets
eliminated then they know they can stay
in if they see that they're actually
none of the other candidates actually
have supporters that support them they
can drop and they can drop sooner
dropping sooner not only helps party
Unity much much quicker but it helps
later States and if later states have
ranked Choice voting what it means is
that those later States primaries their
voters who now currently potentially
waste their votes when they vote on for
a candidate that has already dropped but
dropped too late and so their name is
still on the ballot
or people who have absentee voted or
early voted and they voted for a
candidate who dropped again late having
them drop sooner again produces better
results so having firsts in the nation
as ranked Choice voting or an early uh
primary is ranked Choice voting helps
other states and other voters in other
states have their votes count
so representative Reed we are at the
20-minute Mark which is unprecedented so
I'd ask you to wrap it please we've got
a lot of people after you
foreign
thank you Mr chair
so I'm going to move on to uh
implementation so for primary
implementation again it's only if the
party opts in the counting is done by
the Secretary of State there's
absolutely no change for any of the
workers on the town level so I know
we've heard in years past oh my gosh
will towns be able they don't have to
know how to do it they just have to you
know and we do have education
um every state and everywhere that's
implemented this which is very very
numerous there are organizations they're
willing to do the education but the
actual work for the town workers on the
town level doesn't change at all they do
not have to do any of the counting
results so what we think of as results
and we talk about
um like certified results or official
results from the Secretary of State's
office but that night's results are
preliminary and what we think of those
as results are really what the Press is
reporting that doesn't change towns can
still report their first round numbers
as always and it gets in the press the
same speed as it currently does
um in terms of the actual implementation
there's a few different options but even
the slowest of the options still
produces results within hours
in Maine Maine specifically gives their
towns a week to return information from
their election the actually counting the
actual counting process in Maine is
extremely fast but they don't get the
results from the towns for a week we
require talents to submit information
that night and so the actual process
would happen within a few hours
one of and if we stay with our current
machines which is eventually unlikely
because our machines and has been
reported and talked about extensively
are in desperate need of updating anyway
but if we stay with our current machines
all the ballots would be couriered to
central location for the Secretary of
State's office they rent high-speed
scanners they use open source software
and it that's it it's very simple now we
already Courier things from towns on
Election night anyway
this is by and large how Maine does
theirs Maine also has towns that have
machines that produce the data so we
didn't wouldn't have to move the actual
ballots we could just move flash cards
so whether or not you have an updated
machine doesn't mean you can't do it it
just is the difference between
couriering a box of ballots or occurring
something that big
now as I said we are in I know the
Secretary of State's office has been
looking at new machines and is in the
process of certifying new machines
that may come quickly or not so quickly
we do have excess have a funds we have a
mandate that we have to fund our
elections 10 years out so how much half
of funds we have available for new
machines is in question however I'm
happy to work with the Secretary of
State's office and putting in uh
legislation or working with the Senate
to amend this bill to uh to make sure
Hava funds are available for new
machines if that's the route that the
secretary of state would like to go in
implementation either way it's
completely implementable Maine like I
said has done this exact process we
already Courier they Courier in Maine
they implemented this for twenty nine
thousand dollars up front and then each
election is about 79 000 so very very
affordable
Mr representative that was another three
minutes which is awesome people have
asked for and gone through about half
the a lot of time for the hearing so
please wrap it up respect for the other
folks behind you okay I I do have
respect for the folks behind me
um I will do the best I can Mr chair but
it is a a big deal bill that requires a
lot of introduction
well you have one minute remaining
all right
uh voter experience and voter everywhere
that this is implemented voters exit
polls show that voters understand and
understand how it's counted we're
talking about 70s 80s and 90
they like the process they understand it
and they they think their vote counts
more in terms of arguments the biggest
arguments I usually hear are well it
happened in this location and my guy
didn't win that is never a good reason
to pick an election system you should
pick an election system based on the
fairness I will say that it's pretty
public that I have been a long time
Bernie supporter in this last primary if
we had used ranked Choice voting he
probably would not one have won New
Hampshire and yet I still support it I
will refer you also to the chocolate
election where from last year on this
handout where the original winner was
Almond Joy which I also preferred but
uh did not end up becoming the the final
winner
we should pick election systems based on
fairness
uh finally the idea that it's newfangled
and difficult and hard to understand 27
States on some level have used this sum
since 1912. Australia and about a dozen
other countries have used it on the
national level for over a hundred years
in the case of Australia
um it's used throughout the
English-speaking world it's used for
hundreds and hundreds of organizations
including the Academy Awards including
Mensa
um
there's no issue you can come up with
that hasn't already been addressed by
these entities
paper ballots 100 can be hand counted
absolutely it's been hand counted since
before we had machines to count
um can it be verified Can it can you do
a recount 100 easily done I've done it
in public several times four people to
watch the process so all of those
arguments absolutely are based on a lack
of understanding of uh ranked Choice
voting and I will end by saying anytime
you have Ben Shapiro and Bernie Sanders
agreeing on something as they do with
ranked Choice voting it's probably a
good idea to look into it with an open
open heart and open mind thank you Mr
chair
foreign
thank you we're going to forego
questions right now
good afternoon chairman Smith and
members of the election law committee my
name is Linda Bundy I'm from Antrim
I support HB 345 enabling ranked Choice
voting for State primaries and Municipal
elections in ranked Choice voting voters
rank candidates based on their
individual preferences giving them more
choice because winning requires a
majority of the votes elections result
and candidates supported by more voters
ranked Choice voting increases
competition and candidate interaction
with voters because they must work to
earn the support from a broader range of
Voters
ranked Choice voting Works equally well
when there are multiple seats to fill
elections for municipal offices school
boards floaterial districts and
multi-member districts are ideally
suited for ranked choice
this bill presents an excellent way to
begin using ranked choice in New
Hampshire
it allows parties and municipalities the
opportunity to opt in to this method and
demonstrate its Effectiveness so that
others may follow
thank you
okay my name is Glenn Myers I'm a
retired actuary from Deerfield I've been
in New Hampshire since 2010.
um I want to begin my statement by
looking at the 2022 General and special
elections in Alaska that elected a
representative for the U.S House
what happened on that is that for the
special election they were replacing the
representative Don young who passed away
midterm
and um
what they did right there was that was
the first ranked Choice voting election
that
um
that Alaska held and what happened about
it now if you've got the handout right
um what happens is I put in some of the
round summaries has bar graphs and you
will see that in the first
special election Sarah Palin got the
second most number of votes and
um what happened is that Nick bagich was
eliminated now because we had two
Republicans running against each other
they had a tendency to fight each other
as if this were a primary
and so what happened is that many of
baggage's votes transferred to Sarah
Palin but a few just managed to go over
to the Democrat Mary bartola
and then the next thing you'll notice is
that the green bar down at the bottom
those were the boats where baggage's
people did not vote for a second a rank
a rank behind
um baggage and so if you were to
actually take the exhausted votes and
add them to Sarah Palin's vote that
would have put her ahead
so then what happened is that when they
did the next round Mary patola had
enough to push her over the um top to
get elected
okay now in the runoff then in the
subsequent election okay Republicans
were a little bit upset at that and so
what happens is that they instituted
what they call a rank the red campaign
urging their voters to vote for somebody
in the other party in their next rank
okay and also right there peltola made a
definite
um I'm not sure whether this is shift
but to represent to she hired um Don
Young's former Chief of Staff she
supported the Alaska specific
um policies toward fishing and energy
and as a result right there if you look
at the um next run there behind
um much more many more votes from Sarah
Palin
um
you know I'm basically from baggage went
to
um Sarah Palin there was just enough
votes
for
um for patola to um get elected because
she was the incumbent so she had a good
start on that
okay there's a lesson to be learned from
this basically the moral of the story is
that negative campaigning is very risky
you want to get
the second place votes for other people
that you were attacking before
the other thing right here is that here
you had a palace an election where two
Republican candidates were fighting out
between each other to go after a single
Democrat political parties may want to
resolve any internal differences before
they advance to the general election
okay and that's something that is done
in Maine where they have ranked Choice
voting for both the primaries and for
the general
now the other statement is that voters
should rank multiple if not all
candidates
has I think Ellen pointed out right here
a lower ranked Choice vote will not be
counted as a vote until the higher rank
Choice vote is either eliminated or
elected
so with these um I think is the there's
going to be a learning curve connected
with ranked Choice voting on both the
candidates and the voters part and the I
like the ranked Choice voting because
the skill needed right there to get
elected more closely resembles the skill
needed to get
um to run a government
this is in contrast to some of the
campaigns where the main skill consists
of being able to generate rage against
your opponent
and with that I will finish saying I
really think you should pass this law
anybody have any
foreign
thank you chairman Smith and members um
appreciate you taking a few minutes I'll
be brief
um Eric tur from Brentwood Rockingham
District six
um and
um and basically here primarily to
fulfill a campaign promise that I made
um I was interested in ranked Choice
voting long before I ran for
um
uh office for many of the reasons that
were mentioned by the previous speakers
um as I ran I knocked on probably over
800 doors in my district and I was
surprised that behind taxes and the hot
button social issues that came up
reducing partisanship was one of the top
priorities that I heard from people
um
it was asked of me on candidates night
when we were running what I could do to
reduce partisanship uh ranked Choice
voting has always been my answer for
this uh I think it's the most tangible
and practical solution that we can
Implement
in order to achieve that goal
every person I explained ranked Choice
voting to and some knew who what it was
already but others said it made sense
they liked it they liked that it offered
no partisan Advantage they liked that it
still allowed them to just vote for one
person if that's what if that was their
Preference they don't have to go all the
way
um down the list so
um I guess I'll just summarize and say I
think that this ought to pass and I hope
that's how you'll um how you'll vote on
this measure let towns like mine decide
whether they want to try it or not
um it'll have impacts Beyond just who
wins the election it will change who
runs for elections and who what issues
get discussed thank you
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire I represent the
town of Epsom here in Merrimack County
um I'm opposed to these these two bills
because I think that ranked Choice
voting is flawed it it has many of the
same drawbacks our current system does
and adds new ones
um and and there are better choices I'm
not somebody who inherently is against
alternative voting schemes I've proposed
such bills myself but but this is not
um a particularly good one I've handed
out a piece of paper that gives some
examples of details I'm not going to go
through them but
in particular the first one is a very
simple example of how ranked Choice
voting can choose the wrong winner
right the one that clearly is not the
choice of the voters
and the typical example used here is the
City of Burlington Vermont had ranked
choice for their mayor for a short
period of time and an example similar to
this came up there they picked the wrong
person for mayor people felt it and they
secondly for ranked Choice voting
the counting has to be centralized
and so either as we've heard you ship
all the ballots to Concord and do the
counting there or you have some kind of
computer system where all the towns are
are connected together
um so this is a complex system it's it's
not easy to understand it's more
susceptible to to fraud and error
and so if you're going to do something
this complicated there are better
methods so so effectively if you're
going to put in a computer system to
count all the ballots why not program it
correctly with a better system than this
and and a better example is a system
called condorset
finally this is confusing right so uh
we've heard the example of Australia so
ranked Choice voting was invented in
Australia roughly a hundred years ago I
happen to be visiting Australia once I'm
interested in this issue and I asked
people to explain to me how it worked
you know I I met people randomly a dozen
people who thought it was good and I
said to them explain to me how it's how
they choose the winner not a single
person could explain it to me if you
read the bill starting on page three
you'll understand why I challenge you to
read that stuff
and and understand it it's not easy
okay whereas our current system I think
I could go to anybody and say how does
it work you say we count all the votes
and we the one that's biggest wins right
so it's complicated and so if you're
going to go with this level of
complication there's there are better
choices if you want to stay with the
current level of complication there are
better choices also in particular one
called approval voting
now you've heard a couple of incorrect
things in my opinion reducing
partisanship this is not designed to
reduce partisanship this is designed
because it eliminates the little party
guys from the bottom it keeps the
Democrat and the Republican in play and
it moves the little parties votes into
their columns that's what's going on
there will still be plenty of
partisanship with this method the other
methods that I've talked about really
are non-partisan this one is not
you've also heard a fair amount about
Alaska Alaska's system while technically
called ranked Choice has another large
feature that's not in these bills and so
they they effectively eliminated
separate primaries for republicans and
Democrats so I it's hard to use their
system as an example for what these
bills would do
and with that Mr chairman I will
conclude
are you willing to take questions I am
thank you representative LeBron the only
questions of the hour I guess
um speaking about Australia I looked up
the voting rates in Australia and
learned that they are
mandatory the the Voting is mandatory in
Australia so the voting rates are very
high because you will be fined if you
don't vote I thought that was
interesting did you find when you were
there that there was a lack of
partisanship that there was less
partisanship than say other places
you've been to when you've assessed the
political situation yes thank you for
the question representative
um not specifically although I didn't I
didn't probe sort of those those kind of
question
um but the the general feeling was they
thought they had a great system and I it
was all because it was invented there
right it's ours it must be great right
but but when you ask go into details how
does it work
you know who knows right it's like
anyway
thank you representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman and the committee
I'm Jessica LaMontagne from Stratford
County
I'm going to be very brief
um
I think ranked Choice voting
helps us find the highest common
denominator
among our candidates
um
and that helps us find an affinity for
the candidate that most people like
and I think that in itself is how we
reduce partisanship
and
another thing is the status of being the
first in the nation primary
how more compelling would it be if we're
on the Vanguard
of ranked Choice voting
that further set end
um so I don't want to go into all the
other details that was said
but as far as bills
um being so much more complicated and
the bill
when you look at the legal language
um that's true about almost any bill
that we see in a committee I would say
and I Echo a representative Turner's
impression that one I talked to voters
about it
um they seem to grasp the concept very
easily and we're very much in favor of
it
so thank you
hello thank you
um again I am Tiani Coleman I reside in
Amherst New Hampshire and have been
living there for about nine and a half
years
I um before I moved to Amherst I lived
in Utah and some of you know this
already but um I became introduced and I
got to know ranked Choice voting in Utah
in the early 2000s I was actually at the
time I'm now an independent voter but at
the time I was the chair of the Salt
Lake County Republican party out in Utah
and we used ranked Choice voting for our
Republican conventions in Utah and they
still do use it in the Democratic party
also uses it in their conventions
um we had a race in Utah in in 2002 that
was um a congressional race with 12
candidates and it went very smoothly and
it turned out really well
and then in 2004 we had a race for
governor that had eight candidates this
these were convention races but they
they went very well and since then after
I moved away from Utah in 2018 Utah
adopted a local option bill for their
municipalities to to adopt and use
ranked Choice voting for their Municipal
elections and over over 30 I think it's
20 that have actually used it but over
30 opted in to use it only over 20
actually did use it because some of them
didn't have enough people on the ballot
to actually trigger ranked choice
but
um they have had very positive reviews
and I'm not sure if Amelia Gardner at
the county a former Utah County Clerk
submitted her testimony this year or not
but I know she did last year and she was
a county clerk in Utah County that
implemented it for the first time
and had only positive things to say
about it and it was very good and the
Salt Lake County Clerk also in Utah has
very positive uh things to say about
ranked Choice voting I actually met with
the Salt Lake County Clerk way back in
the early 2000s and you know she had
been fixed County Clerk for a very long
time and at the time she was like uh I
don't know you know I don't know how I
feel about this and all these things but
once they actually implemented it and
she used it she's a big supporter and
you will find that over and over and
over again everywhere where they
implement it it happened with Secretary
of State Dunlap when they were first
bringing the ballot initiative in Maine
the former Secretary of State
um he was a little bit worried about it
negative about it he had things to say
oh I think it might cost too much oh I
think it's going to be complicated oh I
think it's going to be hard to educate
voters but he you know he he was his
hand was forced he had to implement it
because they passed the ballot
initiative and once he implemented it he
only had good things to say they they
were were able to pull it off in two
months I mean they didn't know that they
were going to have to use ranked Choice
voting I think until April it wasn't
finalized that they were going to have
to use it in their June primary and they
pulled it off in two months or so and
had a very positive experience that was
smooth they'd ran exit polls in Maine
over 85 percent of Voters said that they
found it easy to understand easy to use
easy to do over uh I can't remember the
exact numbers was like 60 or 70 percent
said they wanted to keep using it they
loved it and and we see that play out
because in Maine they had another you
know they had to have the have it on the
ballot multiple times different times
and it passed every single time and then
they even expanded it when they first
passed it it wasn't for the presidential
general election or or for the
presidential primaries now they are
using it for the presidential general
election and the presidential primaries
and this is the same story you find
um everywhere where it's been
implemented I you might might know that
I sent you all slides last night that go
into very uh well they were slides now
it's a PDF document but they go into
very a lot of details and you can review
that and one of the slides has
um a link to data from fairvote that has
all of the studies a lot a lot of the
exit polls and all the things that show
all of the positive real world example
results of ranked Choice voting
um you know the positive reviews by
people that they like it the the smooth
implementation of it the very very low
error rate in voter voters casting
ballots
um that I mean they really don't get
very many complaints now some people say
oh you know it took so long and maybe in
Maine or in Alaska or there was a glitch
in New York City all of those none of
those things had to do with ranked
Choice voting every one of those things
had to do with either the law of estate
or a glitch that had nothing to do with
ranked Choice voting like in New York
City
um they really had a very smooth ranked
Choice election they did have a glitch
with ballots prior to that but it wasn't
related to the ranked Choice voting
election itself it was ranked related to
the ballot commission messing up
something in their uh messing up
something in their programming of it had
nothing to do with the ranked Choice
um and the same with Maine and Alaska
the delay in their results is due to
their state law allowing for a lot of
time for the ballots to come in or they
have absentee ballot laws that allow
absentee ballots to come in for two
weeks for example in Alaska so that
would not be you know be relevant here
um I just want to remind all of you one
more time that this bill
um is an enabling Bill only HP 345 it's
only you know to allow municipalities to
opt in if they want
or to allow parties to opt in to use it
in primaries if they want
that really means that all of you really
should support this bill even if you're
not a huge fan of ranked Choice voting
now I know a lot of you are a huge fan
of ring Choice voting but even if you're
not this is a bill that you can support
because what you're saying if you're
someone who supports Liberty and freedom
and good government you would support
giving that option to people who want to
use it if a municipality wants to use it
that's local government control that
small government control that's
something that you should want to let
municipalities opt into if they want to
and they you know they will have to go
through the entire process themselves
to make that determination in a vote of
their own voters but if they want to do
that let them hold a municipal local
municipal election using ranked Choice
voting and the same with parties you
know if if a party really wants their
primary to be held with ranked Choice
voting let them opt into that if if your
party doesn't want to they don't have to
if a party does want to they can and a
party might want to for One race because
they might say oh we know that this
particular primary is going to have a
lot of candidates it's going to be ugly
it's going to result in great party
division we're not going to be able to
unify around someone for a general
election
and you know by allowing them to opt in
you're letting them do that and then
they can opt out if they don't like it
or don't want to use it again or if they
don't need it for a different election I
think you should you know give that
option because believe me people will
want that option
um I um in in party primaries a lot of
times you I think in this last year you
saw what happened with some of the
primaries people weren't really happy
with some of some of the results because
they felt like you know it was a low
percentage and it was a vote split and
rank Choice voting might have helped
that and you saw I I was here earlier
and there there are some people who have
submitted a bill for runoff elections
for primaries and
that shows that people see that there's
a need to do something better than what
we have now
and ranked Choice voting will do that
without the negatives
so since I mentioned that I'll just say
real quickly here too although we can
address it when we're in the next bill
but this bill HB 345
has absolutely zero zero zero
constitutional issues though the whole
plurality provision we can talk about
that on the next bill we'll discuss it
but on this bill it is completely
irrelevant there is no constitutional
issue on this bill whatsoever because
the plurality provision in the New
Hampshire constitution does not in any
way touch primary elections and it does
not in any way touch Municipal elections
and so it is 100 percent not not
relevant
um if you know if you want to talk more
about constitutionality I'm happy to go
into the details in the next bill
um I the same with the other things I
have a lot I could say a lot about
Alaska and what happened there
um and I can talk more about these
alternative voting methods that were
discussed but I think I will save those
for the next bill
and just say that ranked Choice voting
is indeed something that um
that does reduce
um partisanship and helps people
coalesce around each other and it helps
people really have their voice heard and
that's one of the most important things
is that every voter wants to really have
their voice heard and even if I mean if
you go vote and you like someone and
they don't win the way it stands right
now
I mean it's just you feel like your vote
didn't really especially if they only
got you know a small percentage of the
vote you feel you feel like your voice
wasn't really heard
in a ranked Choice voting election it
may not change the outcome but what
happens is that you feel like your voice
was heard because it registers
it registers that you cared about that
person but you can still
voice your choice between
the other people if your person has no
chance of winning so you're able to vote
your vote your conscience and express
how you feel about the top Runners
whereas in a election now you have to
make a choice do I vote my conscience or
do I make a meaningful vote and you have
to choose one or the other you can't do
both and ranked Choice voting you can do
both
um and ranked Choice voting also
um allows people to
it allows people to have a more evil
even a more even playing field right now
a lot of candidates really don't have
much of a chance if they're but once
again I'll talk about that in the next
bill because it's not super applicable
here on this bill that only talks about
primaries and municipalities
so if you have any questions I'm happy
to answer any questions you might have I
will use one more example though real
quick
there was a municipal election that I
brought up last year with the Fall River
Race in Massachusetts that the town the
city of Fall River
and in Fall River there was a mayor who
was under indictment for federal uh tax
evasion I believe in fraud who in the
end did end up getting convicted but at
the time of the election he was under
indictment and so they had a recall
election
and in that recall election over 60
percent of the voters voted to recall
him they did not want him to be the
mayor anymore of that town
but the way that their ballot was was
made they allowed anyone to run so it
said if he's recalled who will you put
in their place and they allowed him to
put his name down as one of the
potential people to be elected so he was
recalled by more than 60 percent of the
vote but then when all of the voters
voted 35 percent of the voters voted
for him but the other 65 voted against
him and but they were split between four
other candidates and so that 35 percent
ended up being the highest percentage
and so he was both recalled and
reinstated in the same election which
was clearly not what the voters wanted
the voters voted to recall them they did
not want him more than 60 percent did
not want him and even in the election
more than 60 percent did not want him
but for those other candidates split the
vote if they had used ranked Choice
voting in that election he would not
have been put he would not been
re-elected in that race obviously the
other four candidates would have ended
up having it producing a winner that
would have beat him out and that's what
ranked Choice voting does is it helps
show who the most voters actually want
um and that's what ranked Choice voting
does as uh as my colleague said before
there's not a 50 threshold in in ranked
Choice voting action there's a 50
threshold for automatic winner but
there's not a 50 requirement meaning
that because voters are not required to
to rank every single candidate they can
only rank one if they want or two if
they want that means that technically
you could get someone who wins at the
end of the day with less than 50 of the
vote but whether it's 50 or a little
less than 50 what it does show for sure
is that you have more you have the the
person who won with more who has the
very most voter support that there's no
one else on the ballot that has more
voter support
um
and I'll take any questions and leave
my name is Nathan Lockwood I'm Executive
Director of National nonprofit
nonpartisan organization called ranked
vote
uh we work with Grassroots volunteer-led
organizations in over 25 States
including in New Hampshire and we're
really excited I just want to be brief
in my points here to to key ones one is
that this is a really exciting thing for
the New Hampshire legislature to have
the ability to move forward with this
bill uh at present there are more than
14 State Legislative there are 14 state
legislators they're
um considering ranked Choice voting
legislation we expect that number to
grow as many of the sessions are just
starting and not all the legislation is
submitted but it's it's got extreme uh
it's it's uh interest in ranked Choice
voting is growing a lot especially
you know in the aftermath of the
um ranked Choice voting was on the
ballot you know across the country in
November and eight of ten of those
referendo were won including in large
many large cities
um ranked Choice voting just another
indication of the of sort of the
mainstream interest and acceptance of it
the Virginia Republican party has become
a big fan of ranked Choice voting for
running their primary elections because
they feel it gives them the candidate
who has the strongest support within
their party and the best chance of
mobilizing their voters and winning the
general election that was how governor
juncken uh was nominated and uh also the
other Statewide candidates will win some
Sears and the others and so they
continued to use it after their first
run there in in Virginia it's kind of an
a little bit different than most States
the the parties have the option of using
the public primary system
or uh doing private primaries and
conducting them as they see fit and so
they chose to take it private and run
ranked choice
so Secretary of State of Georgia Brad
raffensberger is looking to save Georgia
the cost of these expensive Senate
runoffs uh their last two uh Senate
runoffs cost between 50 and 75 million
dollars each and it drags out as other
speakers have talked about drags out the
election season he's presenting three
options before the legislature to
eliminate the runoffs for general
elections and uh ranked Choice voting is
one of them and then Elsewhere on the
political Spectrum Amy Walter of cook
political report recently asked for more
ranks voting across the country for her
uh Christmas present so there you go
it's got got a lot of support in the
mainstream uh political analysts public
officials uh even those responsible for
voting Etc
um real quick thing I want to say is you
know New Hampshire moving forward with
ranked Choice voting today New Hampshire
is a state that has significant
similarities with Maine you know Maine's
kind of a purple State people with range
of perspectives New Hampshire as well I
think
Alaska has a very independent bent which
has some similarities with those States
so and I think the the positive
reception in those States I think you
can be confident you would see here as
well the other great thing about
adopting ranked Choice voting today is
um there's more National organizations
that are better resourced today than
there were even just two years ago or
four years ago and so you've got an
excellent piece of testimony uh that was
submitted from the ranked Choice voting
Resource Center which is the leading
National Organization in terms of
supporting jurisdictions that are either
want to move forward with ranked Choice
voting or in fact are moving forward
with it and I think you'll you'll see
just from the testimony that was
submitted the level of expertise there
and in addition to that expertise uh RCV
resource center and others are willing
to um put resources on the ground to
help uh administrators in New Hampshire
both at the state and local level
support
um candidates who need to learn how to
run under the new system and also
support in voter education efforts
um in Alaska when they move forward in
with all accounts it was a very
successful administrative execution of
their first ranked Choice voting
elections including the special election
which happened earlier than anyone
expected
um National organizations devoted
significant resources probably on the
order of you know over a million dollars
to ensuring uh that uh that the Alaskan
administrators candidates and voters had
the information they need for the most
successful rollout
so um so if you like the benefits and
you want to move forward and I as the
other speakers said there's a lot to
like
um you know strongly encourage you to uh
know that you'll have the support you
need to make it successful so thanks
thank you
good afternoon members of the committee
and the chairman for the record my name
is Olivia Zink and I'm the executive
director of open democracy action a
nonpartisan non-profit Pro voter
organization with 36 000 members and I
live in Franklin New Hampshire
um I'd like to speak about three uh
reasons why I support this bill I think
it's important for us to realize that
almost 13 million voters use ranked
Choice voting we know it works
Massachusetts Cambridge Massachusetts
has used a proportional ranked Choice
voting since
1941 for city council and school
committee nominations
um ranked Choice voting is nonpartisan
it gives voters more choice and a
greater voice at the at the polls
um
ranked Choice voting also decreases
polarization for example if I had this
ballot I personally like moose tracks
ice cream the most and so I would
campaign for moose tracks ice cream but
if you liked vanilla ice cream I
wouldn't necessarily bash you if you
liked vanilla ice cream because you
could choose vanilla as your first
choice and I could convince you that
maybe moose tracks would be your second
choice but if you don't like peanut
butter cups and you want to pick
strawberry ice cream you would do that
but I think voters see and we see so
much negative campaigning in our current
system this is a way where we could be
positive about campaigning and and talk
about the merits of our first choice and
not just bash art our opponents which
our current system does
I also want to speak to ranked Choice
voting in multi-member districts on page
five it says multi-representative but on
I mean page five it talks page five line
11 we talk about multi-member
districts but on page two line 18. many
of you went through the redistricting
process this year and learned about
multi-member districts and I think that
ranked Choice voting in a multi-member
district where it's been gerrymandered
gives voters more voice because they
don't feel like they're
that the the people drawing the map are
drawing the map for any partisan gain
multi-member districts is really where
ranked Choice voting can have a positive
impact
um in those gerrymandered districts and
voters say that gerrymandered districts
lead leads them to not have confidence
in our elections so just wanted to
comment on multi-member districts
with that I'm happy to take questions
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Patricia Lovejoy I am the senior
second senior deputy secretary of state
uh this bill speaks to both
municipalities and to State primaries
since the municipalities run their own
elections and the state does not control
those I will keep my comments just to
the state primaries
um
on a state primary night we don't
necessarily know
we don't know the winners until later
that night and many times it's early in
the morning the next day there are many
districts that are made up of multiple
towns I think the largest is 16 towns so
we accumulate all those information we
wouldn't know until that point that
there was going to be a ranked Choice
voting runoff in effect for that
election
on Election night people mentioned
earlier about the couriers who bring
information to us those couriers are our
state police they are bringing to us a
iPad from each town which was used for
the one for all system and a one-page
return of votes the state police would
not have the ability to put all of the
ballots from each of the towns that
they're transporting that information to
us in their Cruisers
uh once you've once you know which towns
are which races are going to have
um ranked Choice voting those ballots
would need to be transported to Concord
um I'm assuming that the plans would be
that you'd be using a high-speed scanner
we are already doing high-speed scans
something that was passed last year for
post-election audits
in November we did four it took the
better part of a of a day to do the
high-speed scanning for the four towns
that were selected
uh I think that if we were to have
ranked Choice voting you would probably
need to move off the date
that someone gets to request a recount
right now the election is on Tuesday you
have until 5 PM on Friday to request a
recount if we have to go through the
ranked Choice voting procedure I think
you would probably have to move that off
which it's sort of a domino effect we'll
continue to move other other dates off
if there is ranked Choice voting in New
Hampshire any recounts
are done manually you're not allowed to
use a high speed scanner obviously you
can change those laws but right now all
recounts are done by hand so if we if
after
you've gone through this right choice
voting one of the candidates requests a
recount we would be doing a recount by
hand and also doing the ranked Choice
voting by hand so these are other issues
that you need to think of if you were to
go forward with these bills
my biggest concern is the uakava
deadline
as you know we only have eight weeks
between our primary and our general
election
if we are doing the ranked Choice voting
and you potentially have to move off the
date of that someone can ask for a
recount and then we do those recounts by
hand and we have to do the ranked Choice
voting by hand
the date that we are going to know be
able to declare who is the winner of the
primary we'll go on to the general
election
we would not have enough time
to electronically prepare those ballots
so that they can be sent off in the
45-day euacaba deadline there is no you
will cover deadline related to Municipal
elections So This only affects the um
the federal election you know if we are
talking in terms of a U.S Senate or a
person Nation primary you were talking
about all the ballots in the state
coming to to Concord
um I suggested that would probably be a
reasonably lengthy process the the
Secretary of State wants to go on record
that he is against any
um any bills that would make it so that
we do not know who the winner is on
Election nine especially for the first
representative excuse me representative
wary
yes uh thank you for your testimony uh
if there was a recount request would
there be a breakdown of for the ranked
Choice voting of the different uh
runoffs and what they've produced in
getting to that uh majority winner I'm
sure we would have that information but
we are required to do to count each
ballot and do it by hand so unless you
change the laws to allow recounts to be
to use high-speed scanning or something
we would still need to even though we
know we always know what the results
were on Election night but we then have
to hand count the ballots
I'm sorry maybe uh follow up follow up
I'm not sure I made my uh question clear
I apologize for that is
um in the ranked Choice voting process
different candidates are eliminated and
then uh votes are shifted and and
accordingly would those different
sequences of counting votes be available
as part of the recount process so that
there was a kind of transparency as to
how different candidates were eliminated
and then selected I think that we would
need to go through that same that same
process of eliminating the lower
candidates and then re-looking at who
everyone put as their second choice of
those uh voters for the candidates that
were eliminated I mean unless
unless the legislature changes that
process that would everything that the
high-speed scanner did we would be doing
representative ankenberg can you send me
up the blue sheet please thank you
representative Berry
uh thank you
um I'm glad you brought up the first in
the nation because I was the one that
was sitting on my my head my brain
um
so a party adopts this
and they use this method
all the ballots we use paper ballots in
New Hampshire so all the ballots have to
go to Concord
it took you a day to do four towns I
assumed that you would try to expand
that process and assume that
um would we have the results by the time
the next state was Voting because right
now we're a week ahead right by law
would we even have our results by the
time the next state voted I I can't tell
you that for sure I mean obviously we If
This Were to to go through and it were
going to be for the First Nation primary
we would probably have to arrange to
have a lot of high-speed scanners but we
need to keep the votes from every town
separate and we have 320 voting
locations in the state we can't
commingle ballots so there's just
there's a
um you know an actual process that that
follow up going back to the first the
nation primary
um we the Secretary of State's office uh
changes the ballot order right so you
like all those ballots aren't even the
same so even if you wanted to come
England right you couldn't you couldn't
um no okay it's it is um
various ballot as to who's going to be
first on the ballot the order in a
primary is different obviously than the
general election the general election
which which one is um is first and
second and uh third in in the columns
goes by what Senate District you're in
so but a primary is a little bit
different
um so the ballot will the ballot at
least at the presidential would
basically be the same for for each of
them but there will be some that are
hand count ballots which don't have the
same timing marks they're not the same
ballot as those that go through the Accu
so I guess for just if you were going to
go forward with something like this I
think you would have to do it in
conjunction with moving the data the
primary
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman uh
so uh when we are looking at delays in
counting the votes we have a provisional
ballot system that prevents us from
knowing the actual total a week after
the election uh so in terms of counting
up all of these uh additional ranked
Choice votes that really would not delay
I mean you have to go through the
physical process of doing of scanning
and
all of those ballots so obviously that's
going to delay it you're not going to
have your your results that night the
provisional ballots which we'll be doing
with the first time
um next month is only related to
first-time voters who don't have their
um don't have their information and you
would know on Election night that a town
had
six provisional ballots and if there's
no race that has a difference of more
than six you're not going to have a um
it's not going to change your outcome it
may change the actual count but it's not
foreign
thank you Mr chair thank you for the
question taking the question do you know
offhand how many of the 320 voting
locations um use scanners roughly
you scan nobody uses scanners they use
the accuvote machines
um I actually have the number back my
office uh it's almost half that are by
hand but they're they're but of those
320. the the ones that do it by um hand
count don't amount to 50 of the of the
votes by any means
so you might have noticed me Crossing
names off of the blue sheet that is
because some people
send in a pink card speak and then sign
the blue sheet you cannot be on both
so there were representative churner and
Linda Bundy who did speak so I just took
them off of this of the remaining
by people's five people signed in in
favor to against and that concludes the
foreign
all right
we will open the public hearing on House
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
honorable members
um so I'm just going to roll straight
into uh the next bill which we
affectionately termed the big bill
um without trying trying to not repeat
um things that were previously said on
the previous bill
um this bill uh the first it's staged
implementation there are three stages
the first stage is essentially more or
less identical to the bill that you just
heard where it enables municipalities
and parties to run it for their
Municipal elections and party primaries
that is for becomes uh
it is uh
in effect is the word I was looking for
in effect for the end of this year for
next year's primaries
um 2024 for the second stage it applies
to Federal races that would go into
effect for 2025 for the 2026 election
um and then the final stage is for all
state elections would go into effect
2027 for the 2028 election
um as a previous speaker mentioned the
issue of the plurality provision in our
constitution does not at all touch
Municipal elections it does not at all
touch uh primaries it also does not at
all touch and could not touch Federal
races it only has to do with State races
which is why the state races are the
last stage so we have a good five years
to pull the plug if there were any
problems I will also mention that we do
have severability in this state so even
if this were to pass and at some point
it were to be challenged which I will
bring up but I also have a lawyer and an
expert that will will speak in more in
depth to it why we think it's completely
constitutional but if it were to be
challenged on the first two pieces the
first two stages of implementation would
remain intact the only piece that's
touched by that plurality provision is
the last piece again which is why it is
last
some of the things that didn't really uh
have so much of a bearing on the
previous bill that are in this bill is
the issue of multi-winner districts
multi-winter districts are like many of
our State Rep districts where instead of
one winner you have multiple winners
ranked Choice voting when it's done in a
multi-member district produces a
wonderful effect of proportionality
through something that some people refer
to as proportional RCV also known as
single transferable vote specifically
there are different flavors of single
transferable vote this bill spells out
what is known as the Scottish method and
it's known as the Scottish method
because the Scots use it
um it is vastly superior and in fact in
and of itself proportional RCV done in
multi-member districts is by itself a
good reason to adopt ranked Choice
voting because when you have a
multi-member district let's say you have
a district with seven reps
let's say that district is 60 percent uh
orange party and 40 percent purple party
very frequently what happens is known as
a single party sweep all seven of those
seats go to the orange party none to the
purple party even though 40 percent of
that entire District deserves
representation and you have the ability
to give them some of the representation
say three of those seven seats in uh
proportional RCV single transferable
vote it produces those proportional
results so you have that seven member
district four would go to the orange
party three would go to the purple party
in that example
just to touch once again on
implementation very similar to The
implementation discussion earlier it has
since it has been implemented in many
places we know that it's completely
doable we also know that the counting of
ranked Choice voting results is very
very very fast the only thing that adds
time is the couriering and we already
Courier on Election night we already do
that the furthest place we so main
couriers Maine is a much larger
geographical State than we are
um the furthest place in this state is
about three hours away from Concord so
it with handling and whatever you're
talking about a four two I would say
probably not more than six hour uh Delay
from the careering effect
um I would also like to talk about the
polarization civility as it pertains
specifically to this bill
um
before we were talking about in party
primaries but when we're talking about
in regular races where we're talking
about the two major parties going
head-to-head we all know how bad
polarization is in fact there's lots and
lots of data and I think you actually
have some testimonies submitted to you
already about the increasing
polarization of our country not just in
the recent years but over the last many
decades and how it's not just a blip and
not just a natural ebb and flow of
democracy but in fact it has gotten
worse and worse because of the two-party
effect let me just be very very clear in
the Constitution and I teach American
government as a part-time job
for Community College we do not we are
not supposed to have a two-party system
that is not in the Constitution anywhere
in fact our founding fathers vehemently
hated what they called factions what we
call parties they hated the idea of
parties for this very reason two the
two-party system as we frequently bemoan
it is a result of our first pass the
post system and winner take all that is
what happens you get forced like I said
before the only there's only two
candidates that ever matter the one in
the top and the one that's best in a
position to to oust that person that is
why and that is also why the two parties
start to become bitter and it's all a
scare tactic to make you afraid of them
and it doesn't matter if this party is
that great because there's no other real
options because we're in the best
position one of the previous speakers
against the last bill was saying
something to the effect of well ranked
Choice voting still helps the two
parties no it has an even playing field
in our current situation the two parties
have more funding and so probably would
still control and come in top for most
of the elections just from that aspect
alone but over time because it isn't
even playing field you're allowing
independent candidates third party
candidates low dollar candidates to all
compete on even playing field of ideas
ideas only not oh my God I'm so scared I
really like this candidate but I'm
afraid of voting for them because I'm
afraid that the other guy will win
that you have some testimony who's been
submitted to you from Amy Smith who is a
main register of Voters
she also 30 years ago was a scholar of
international ethnic conflict and she
writes in her testimony that the low
plurality winners and first pass the
post systems in the countries that she
was studying exacerbated the distrust
the unrest and the violence in those
countries built between the political
factions because the winners were not
seen as valid that has to ring a bell
for some of you the winners were not
seen as valid and I don't care if it's
the last election cycle or the one
before that or the one before that we or
hearing this increasingly no matter who
wins
she then goes on to write but 30 years
ago mind you
she witnessed that in Bosnia Estonia Sri
Lanka and Ireland they all successfully
implemented ranked Choice voting and
then successfully decreased the unrest
because winners were seen as having
actual broad support
that is significant and it's significant
for a reason I also talked to my
children my children my kids my two
students about
because it turns out psychologically
people accept results when they believe
the system is fair when they think it's
fair and it's done correctly they accept
when their guy doesn't win
because hey that's just how it goes it's
only when they think it's unfair that
you end up with the Civil rest and the
bitterness and the hatred that we're
experiencing
on to the plurality uh issue
so our constitution like I said was
amended because of that political gaming
of the majority requirement and running
people to spoil the other party in the
legislature determining outcomes
our plurality provision applies to a
number of State offices however ranked
Choice voting is the method for
determining plurality as I said not all
and it's defined in the bill not all
uh ranked respawning winners end up with
a plurality because if voters do not
exhaust all their preferences then the
person who wins may not have 50 of the
vote
and indeed a multi-member districts none
of them have or many of them will not
have 50 of the vote inherently so we do
not have a requirement for majority you
get more frequent majority winners
because we're finding the best possible
plurality
um I will wrap up by briefly talking
about the concept of alternative systems
that was brought up before so arrows
theorem uh is a election theory that
actually the the Creator uh Dr Arrow won
the Nobel Prize for in it he lists four
fairness principles for any election
system and he proved mathematically that
there is no system in existence that can
meet all four there are systems that do
not meet three but there's no system
that meets all four ranked Choice voting
meets three
um and it is not just in many ways the
best of all the alternative systems it
is definitely the only alternative
system that has real world data real
world use for over a hundred years I
might add in as I said a dozen countries
or so 20-something states on the local
level also used for overseas and
Military ballots and State that do run
off elections so if you have a runoff
election but you're overseas those
States like Georgia they send you a
ballot that's ranked Choice voting in
essence because you don't have time as
an overseas voter to engage in a runoff
election so they let you go ahead and
say who would you vote for if it does go
to runoff that's rank Choice voting
that's all it is
so um it's been done for 100 years in
many many locations and I will finally
add that in case anybody still thinks
that it's a partisan thing or
people support it because maybe certain
ideologies are it benefits or certain
ideologies I will say that not only as
was mentioned the Virginia GOP
instituted and actually ended up with an
upset over the Democratic candidate for
governor by their candidate was selected
by ranked Choice voting the Utah GOP has
used it for over 20 years the
libertarian party has used it for over
20 years internally Australia which
we've talked about frequently that's
used over 100 years famously elects far
more conservatives than any other
Western democracy western style
democracy with maybe the exception of
the United States it's it doesn't pick
ideologies look through the bill you
can't pick anything that's an ideology
in that bill it's all about what it
represents so it doesn't give preferred
treatment to conservatives liberals
Independents or anybody else it does
give preferred treatment to the truth so
if you have a rural country like
Australia it's probably going to come
out like a conservative election right
but if you have a populist that is
leaning to the left in election that's
probably what you're going to get
so um with that I'll happily take
questions and let the experts kind of
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Reed for taking my
question
um so how feasible is a manual audit in
ranked Choice voting election I ask
because one voter has written that she
is opposed to rank Choice voting because
she believes hand counted audits would
be difficult
she says that due to the quote threats
of hacking and rigging and the lack of
confidence in our voting machines
unquote
that there is a critical need for manual
auditing
over this past summer representative
that's
we're asking questions that's a lot of
testimony being read in so I think I
kind of we probably understood your
question and we can go from there I mean
I appreciate you stopping the testimony
against my bill Mr chairman the
testimony she was reading not the
testimony she was giving but I
understand the question yeah manual
audits
um extremely doable by hand I've done
probably close to two dozen ranked
Choice voting elections ranging in 102
close to 400 votes by hand in public for
people to see then with usually my
colleague behind me doing it again to
double check the numbers all usually
within about an hour the method of
choice when doing because again there's
best best practices for all of this
because this is all very well trodden
paths a hundred years of countries and
states and cities and organizations
doing this well trodden the best
practice for doing it by hand is called
stack and sort the stack and sort method
sound is exactly what it sounds like
it's stacking and sorting you sort them
out by the first preference you take the
smallest stack and then if you don't
have a winner you reallocate this the
shortest stack it takes a little extra
time than counting by hand in a
conventional election a little maybe up
to about fifty percent and the reason
it's so little extra is because you're
not dealing with all of those ballots
you're dealing with the shortest Stacks
the eliminated Stacks which are pretty
short and small so those are the only
ballots you touch more than once and
because of that it only takes a little
bit more time than counting a normal
Race by hand which is one of the reasons
I think that some of the objections that
or concerns that the Secretary of
State's office has expressed are
actually not founded and not based in
for the questions representative where
thank you Mr chair uh representative we
thank you for your uh testimony there
um
in Australia policy has talked about
that over the long term
in using ranked Choice voting it's led
to a predominant two-party system with
detriments to minority voters and
independents do you think the bill has
written would prevent that sort of thing
happening within
New Hampshire if you if you're asking if
I think that right choice voting as a
reform on its own is a Panacea a silver
bullet for all ills then the answer is
no of course not but I think it's a
major major
um reform that goes a very very long way
towards fixing a lot of problems
including these so not the parties
themselves it doesn't ban the two
parties and it doesn't take away their
money so they still have a lot of clout
and power but it allows an even playing
field which can at least provide room
for other parties and other candidates
to grow
so in that aspect it is very beneficial
helps just release the Stranglehold the
two parties have on the system but it
doesn't guarantee the wonderful robust
democracy that we would all like to see
foreign
welcome to election law Mr Myers okay
well it's my second try
okay
um I'm going to focus on you know the
part of the 350 that focuses on the
House of Representatives where we have
multi-member districts now if two if I
looked at the 220 election you will find
that of the 99 multi-member districts 81
of them had representatives from a
single party
I think 41 were Democrats and 40 were
Republicans
now what I want to do is illustrate what
happens when you have ranked Choice
voting with multi-member districts now
I'm created I think an artificial
example but I think it will I think draw
home the point as to how this works
um I have three candidates from what we
call the a party and three candidates
from the B party and if you flip over to
the opposite side of the handout I gave
um if you take a look at the round 1A in
the upper left-hand corner
you will see the way I set up this
election is that the three candidates
from the a party won you know they had
the most votes
okay and then what happens is when you
go into ranked Choice voting okay they
eliminate the
um party the the least number of votes
from the B party in this case it's what
I call the Tiger
and what happens then is the tiger
transfer his votes to the other two
members of the B party
that if you take a look at the right
hand side
of um you know round 1B there you will
see that now the B party candidates have
the most votes but they are not quite up
to the threshold for
um to get elected so then what they do
is we now eliminate the lowest vote
count from the a party
and you can see right away what happens
here is that the A party's only going to
get at most two candidates
okay and then you know what happens is
that the smallest one from the a party
basically transfers his boats to the
other members of the a party and that
pushes them over the threshold to get
elected and that leaves just simply one
seat to be filled with two b-party
candidates to be filled
okay so um what this does then it shows
you how ranked Choice voting actually
contributes to
um
um proportionality and in general what
we're going to see is that ranked Choice
voting splits the number of seats by
party in proportion to the number of
party votes
and now
um what I tried right here is to see
what would happen if we were to
implement
Implement ranked Choice voting for the
house and I could get went through the
Secretary of State's website got the
vote totals for all of our district all
the multi-member districts and what I
did is I just basically made the
assumption that people would rank only
those people in their party
and I it's a simulated election in the
real ones would be probably different in
the candidates that would win these
simulated elections but the vote count
the seat count is going to be pretty
good and so what happened right here is
in the simulated election there were
only four
seats four districts with party sweeps
and if this were to be implemented say
tomorrow or for the 2024 election the
house makeup is going to be very
different
you're going to have Republicans from
democratic districts and you're going to
have Democrats from Republican districts
and myself I think that is a very good
thing I think that multi-party
representing for districts would serve
better serve the citizens of New
Hampshire
now rather than use the current
districts okay like there's one District
I think Hudson Pelham that has 11 to 11
member district
all are Republicans because that's the
way people vote in these things
um I would say that we ought to do
implement this after we do some
redistricting and I would suggest we
follow what's being
proposed in the
um for the national elections there's
votes in Congress that are saying we do
this and that you redistrict and you
have anywhere between three and five
member districts
and um that would take some time and
also
um for basically Representatives who
um are planning on running for a long
time they'll give them time to adjust to
the new multi-party agenda so I would
say
um start thinking about this soon so we
can implement it by the time we do
redistricting again
thank you um any questions from the
committee
I'm sure everyone's looking forward to
redistricting again
I I will say for a statement of fact I
am one of the 18 out of 99 who come from
a split member seat I got first in case
anybody's wondering okay okay
all right next uh any questions from the
committee
hello uh and when I testified in the
last bill I just said my name and where
I was from Amherst New Hampshire but
I've neglected to say that I'm also
representing New Hampshire ranked Choice
voting I do represent them as a
volunteer I did not get paid to do this
I did not get paid from them we are a
completely volunteer organization all
across the board we don't have any paid
stuff we have uh
thousands of supporters so um there are
a lot of people here who do support
ranked Choice voting I am also an
attorney I'm licensed to practice law
here in New Hampshire
so I just wanted to let you know about
that now as far as this bill goes as it
was pointed out
um this bill now as opposed to the last
bill that we talked about this bill
would now you know have ranked Choice
voting between the parties whereas the
last bill would have only been relevant
in uh primaries and it would only have
been relevant in uh Municipal elections
so it wouldn't have been anything to do
with the partisanship involved but this
one you know is ranked Choice voting
between the parties and once again I
would like to point out that it has
broad support across many different
parties as has been pointed out
um
there were a number of states who
elected to use ranked show as voting for
their uh presidential primaries in 2020
on the Democratic side on the Republican
side as was pointed out it was used in
the Republican
um primary in Virginia and um in Utah
which is a very Republican state they
have every single uh Congressional race
and every single
I mean every single a federal seat as
well as a
super majority in the legislature an
All-State office Statewide office
holders governor and attorney general
Etc they're all Republicans so it's a
very Republican state they're not using
it yet in their Statewide elections but
you know they do use ranked Choice
voting as I already pointed out in many
many of their cities and they like it
and they use it in their own conventions
so
um and the libertarian party uses it and
other parties use it as well so right
choice voting and Alaska adopted it
which is a Republican state so franchise
voting you know is a a reform that is
supported by both major parties as well
as minor parties
some people I remember last year some
people indicated that one person
actually objected to this because they
said it would not help third parties and
then other people are worried that it's
going to help third parties when it
shouldn't help third parties so let me
just explain what it does what it does
is it like we've already said it gives
people an even playing field what it
does is it lets people vote for third
parties if they really want to whereas
right now sometimes they don't feel like
they can it does not mean that it's
going to
suddenly make third parties win
elections in New Hampshire
most likely you know they won't win at
first for a while it might take time but
maybe down the road they'll start
winning elections because the playing
field has been more even but even though
they may not win immediately what it
does do as I already mentioned is it
lets them have a better voice because it
let as was asked in one of the previous
questions is whether the data would be
you know transparent yes ranked Choice
voting always produces very transparent
data there was someone who testified
last year who actually showed you know
the cast vote record from Maine
where you can see you know
where the votes went
so each each vote for each person you
see where they went to each candidate
and so you're able to see very very
clearly you start to realize wait a
minute maybe maybe people are more
nuanced than we thought maybe people
aren't so partisan as we think right now
we just assume everyone's partisan
because all the elections are very
partisan one versus the other all the
time but when you actually look at a
Casper record you might see that you
know maybe the Republican maybe the
Libertarians don't always go for the
Republican or maybe they do maybe the
green party doesn't always go for the
Democrat or maybe they do but the point
is is that is that it's it's more
nuanced because people often do vote for
the person over the party
um but you're able to start that that
helps candidates actually realize oh I
need to speak to a broader base of
Voters maybe not all my voters like my
party points so much they actually want
to have me address this issue that this
guy's addressing because this guy got
this many votes and his his second place
didn't go to me it went to the other
person be because I'm not addressing
those issues at all and so it actually
helps us have a better system of
government where more people are being
heard more people are addressing those
issues
I know that some people are concerned
with some of the election results that
have happened in a few places such as
Maine or Alaska now as far as Alaska
goes we'll just quickly get that one
over with as it's been pointed out
Alaska uses a different system than this
bill would would Implement because they
have a combined primary rather than
separate party primaries and so it's
different and the other thing that's
different about Alaska is some people
might have been upset that Sarah Palin
didn't win
ultimately
but if it were a regular election she
wouldn't have won either in that
election because she was not the first
place winner the first place winner was
patola in Alaska and so had it used our
current system patola would have won and
in the ranked Choice voting patola won
so she would have won in either system
so Sarah Palin's losing wasn't really
because of ranked Choice voting
um some people have complained about
what happened in Maine so we'll talk
about that really quick
um this is talking about the election in
2018 between Jared golden and Bruce
poliquin
in that race uh golden
came in second after they counted
everyone's First Choice votes and after
and then when they ran but nobody got a
majority and after they ran the election
um it turned out that in the end uh
um in that race there were two
independent candidates who had a lot of
support
and you know for for as far as
independent candidates go I think it was
like a total of 14 of the total vote
that they got which is quite a bit
usually for an independent candidate and
Paula Quinn didn't reach out to those
independent voters at all whereas golden
did
um paulikan told his voters not to rank
anyone second all of that
um golden did all of those kinds of
things and so in the end you know the
the third party candidates preferred
golden over poloquin but they could have
very easily preferred
call it Quinn over golden and in a lot
of other races were Ranger studying
Choice voting takes place the opposite
happens so the point is that a ranked
Choice voting election ultimately
decides the person who has the most
overall voter support
it is not favor one party over the other
it really favors whoever the voters want
and in some elections the voters are
going to want a republican some
elections the voters are going to want a
Democrat
um ranked Choice voting in and of itself
does not favor one party over the other
um I I gave in my slides some examples
because ranked Choice voting has three
different kinds of examples that happen
every day in some exam and many many in
fact the vast majority of examples of A
ranked Choice voting election
somebody wins after the first round of
counting
um because they they get 50 and that
means that nobody else can get more than
that even if they run all the rounds no
one's going to pass them up because they
already have 50 more than 50 percent and
so a lot of people will be will win that
very first round of counting and they
won't have to run any more rounds
because they win on that first round
there's also the example where someone
is ahead in the first round
but they don't get more than 50 so they
keep running the rounds and in the end
they still win even though they ran the
other rounds it's not like they suddenly
the first person of suddenly lost they
can still win so some people might think
they'll rank towards voting is where the
winner ends up losing no the winner
often ends up winning in fact
more elections end up that way where the
person who's first still stays ahead and
wins so it's only you know some of those
elections where there is a vote a clear
vote split that shouldn't exist and
where those voters really do prefer the
other person that's where you actually
have the person in second or third
ending up winning after the ranked
Choice
um elections take it takes place
um I just want to answer a couple of
things that have been brought up really
quickly as someone brought up that
Burlington Vermont stopped using rain
Choice voting well they're using it
again so they are using it again
um and also
um as far I think representative Reid
already addressed the issue of other
methods of voting but yes ranked Choice
voting is the best method if anyone
wants to talk to us about all the
different methods as she said it's not
perfect but overall there it checks more
boxes than the other methods and overall
is the best is the best method of of the
methods that are out there
um
as far as someone has been mentioned
that hand count towns I mean that if you
do a recount it's going to take so much
longer
once again if you have to do a hand
recount
or if you have to count everything by
hand in general it's always going to
take longer than if you use you know the
accuvote machines or any other kind of
voting machine so the ranked Choice
voting part of it is only going to add a
little bit more to that so yes a hand
count takes longer than the machine
count that's that's a given hand count
takes longer than machine count but
um doing the ranked Choice voting if a
hand count is just that much longer than
a hand count so it's it's not a ranked
Choice voting hand count isn't that much
longer than the machine count Cambridge
Massachusetts has always been doing
their ranked Choice votings purely by
hand count
um
as far and once again
um you know all of the machines on the
market right now for voting
have RCV compatible files
have the capacity for the RCV compatible
files and we know that you know we just
they just released the voter confidence
committee asking you know saying that we
need new machines I think it's pretty
much everyone knows we need new machines
here in New Hampshire so although ranked
Choice voting can take place without
machines you know it would be better if
we did have the machines
um and so we need we do need to get
those new machines and we do need to
allocate have a funds towards having
machines that's something that we need
with or without ranked Choice voting we
need new voting machines so that would
be faster and more efficient and as was
mentioned earlier in Maine once they
actually get all the ballots or all of
the duplicate drives of
um they are able to run those ranked
Choice voting really fast and it's fully
transparent they did it in the open they
did it live on Facebook everyone could
watch it they also let people come and
watch it
um they it was very very quick and
everyone can see exactly what happened
they understand stand exactly where the
votes went exactly how it's very easy to
understand so it's not at all confusing
it's not at all something where people
are like I don't know what happened I
don't understand this person won and I
don't know why that's that's not at all
it happens people know exactly and
understand it perfectly so I don't think
there's really anything else
I need to point out except for this
constitutionality issue that has come
out because I am an attorney and I have
spent a lot of time with this issue so
as was already mentioned
um there's no issue whatsoever with the
other bill on this bill it's there's
only a an issue when I say issue I mean
it's only a potential issue with regards
to the state races so it's not an issue
at all with regards to Federal races in
regards to ranked Choice voting
elections for president for U.S Congress
for U.S Senate it's not issue at all for
primary or general and it's no issue at
all for primary elections for any races
so only for races so for general
elections for State office that's the
only time where even is an issue that
needs to be discussed
as far as whether it needs to be
discussed I you probably don't want to
hear an entire legal lecture but I can
go through it point point by point two
things to understand many things to
understand but one thing is Although our
constitutional provision on plurality is
very similar to Maine's constitutional
provision on plurality the bill here in
New Hampshire is different than the
language of their
ballot measure that they had that
implemented ranked Choice voting so in
our bill nowhere nowhere does it say
that someone has to give a majority to
win and also in this bill in HB 350 it
says that when when the winner is
expressed as a percentage it's expressed
as a percentage of total ballots cast
and so
um that would be you know the percentage
from the very first round not just the
last percentage which means that you
know it's not requiring someone to have
a majority in order to win someone could
win without a majority
um if you go through all of the rounds
and enough people didn't Express you
know their preferences that you know
nobody gets a final majority no it will
almost always result in the majority and
that's a good thing you want elections
actually to result majority but it
doesn't have to and it's not requiring
it and so therefore it would not be
unconstitutional because we're not
requiring someone to have a majority in
order to win
also as I pointed out and if you care to
look there is a law review article that
came out in California law review
just last year
where two professors from NYU do
in-depth and depth research where they
evaluate every single State's plurality
for every single state that has a
plurality provision and they're saying
that even states that don't say
plurality if they say most votes that's
also the same thing because that is what
plurality means is Whoever has the most
votes and they evaluated all of those
and they conclude that those provisions
and state constitutions do not are not
um in conflict with con with
not make ranked Choice voting
unconstitutional in those states that it
should still be constitutional so they
are they argue very clearly why they
think that the main advisory opinion was
an incorrect opinion
um the main advisory opinion
um
it was only an advisory opinion so it's
not it's it's not binding on Maine it
was never decided final decision on the
merits it's certainly not binding on New
Hampshire but also you know they don't
think it was decided correctly anyway
um and then the main points on that are
just that you know in a ranked Choice
voting election it's not just it's not
saying someone has to win by plurality
obviously someone can win by majority
people win by majority now and it
doesn't conflict right is saying by a
plurality of the vote meaning they're
not requiring a majority right well it's
not just the plurality word it's also
the vote plurality of the vote and in
ranked Choice voting your vote is your
entire ballot when you come you cast a
vote your vote is all your rankings all
your rankings are your vote and so your
entire vote needs to be counted in order
to determine who has the most votes if
you don't count the entire ballot then
you haven't determined who got the most
votes it would be like stopping an
election before you've counted all the
precincts and so for that reason it does
not violate the plurality provision and
once again you know representative Reed
mentioned the 50 threshold the 50
threshold is not a threshold that
someone has to get in order to win the
election it's the threshold that someone
could win outright before running the
rest of the ballots before running the
rest of the rounds just because
if someone gets that before you run all
the rounds it's mathematically
impossible for anyone else to win so you
already have a winner but they don't
have to get that in order to win there's
no threshold to win the threshold to win
is just run all the ballots unless
someone wins sooner run all the rounds I
mean and run all the rounds unless
someone wins dinner so that's that's
that in a nutshell if you have any other
questions I'm happy to answer them any
questions from the committee
saying none thank you Miss Coleman
um next up is Nathan Lockwood uh from
hi thanks yeah so Nathan Lockwood of
ranked the vote from Lunenburg Mass
um yeah just a couple real quick things
I think a lot of a lot of it's been
covered here I want to go back to talk a
little bit about
um issues related to counting the
ballots and speed of counting the
ballots uh in this regard I want to
refer back to that testimony from the
ranked Choice voting Resource Center
which goes into some depth on you know
the the possibilities here just to
briefly review there's a few different
scenarios which for what the speed
potential speed of counting would be in
New Hampshire depending on whether you
update your election equipment or not
but one thing just to address that a
concern that the deputy deputy secretary
of state brought up was the ability of
the current couriers the state police to
transport all of the the ballots which
you know that would obviously have to be
there might have to be some change there
if they're just you know using their
their cars or whatever
um one possibility if your machines were
upgraded they could be what they would
be transporting is not they wouldn't
have to transport that balance on
Election I think it could transport that
memory cards basically and then you
would get basically they would get them
pull the memory cards duplicate them so
they have a backup send a send a copy of
the memory card with a courier never
connecting to the internet throughout
this process
and then uh when that was received in
the state that memory card would just be
uploaded
and the electronic tally uh could occur
quite rapidly
um the other thing that regardless of
whether you upgrade your Machinery in
New Hampshire or not you could get an
initial count of the first preferences
uh in the same way that you get your
account however you get it right now off
your your current ballots uh meaning the
precincts would be reporting
the the number of uh first choices that
each candidate got and that would be
transmitted in whatever form you're
doing now to the uh to the central
location and and that could be reported
as a preliminary result is as well
um a couple other kind of Innovations in
terms of counting and transparency uh
the State of the State of there's a
couple jurisdictions that you know
ranked Choice voting
uh in the U.S is really grown a lot as
folks have described since about the
early 2000s and uh
and uh there's some great examples of
transparency in Maine for example and I
believe other jurisdictions do this as
well all of the cast vote records from
each Precinct are made immediately
available to
the public basically so if anyone wants
to check the Secretary of State's Mains
math they can take the same data the
secretary is using and run it on their
own
um the other the other the other example
of transparency outside and I don't know
if Maine does this San Francisco is a
jurisdiction that's been using ranked
Choice voting since 2005. uh they
recently updated their election
equipment one of the features of this
highly secure equipment is that it
captures an image of each ballot cast so
in addition to the tabulated cast vote
record which gives you a mathematical
description of the values on every vote
cast they actually have a photo image of
every ballot that is uh available the
public and can be inspected and you can
actually go download it from the board
of elections in San Francisco's website
uh so there's some some nice
transparency features that are offered
by modern technology the recommendation
is is Tiani mentioned would be to do
machine counting uh Cambridge actually
did upgrade to machine counting I think
in the mid 90s there are jurisdictions
that still do hand counting in the US
not a lot I think St Paul was they may
have upgraded since that said Austria
Australia and Ireland who both use have
used ranked Choice voting for over 100
years uh both are still using hand
counting
um Australia started to automate the
ranked Choice vote account for their
senate elections but their house
elections still hand counted and in
Ireland it's all all hand counting so
it's it's very feasible I mean Ireland I
think is over 4 million people uh they
actually have as many members in their
lower house as we have in the state
house in Massachusetts it's about 160.
uh you folks have more uh more electives
actually than than either of us in that
regard but it would still work well
um
you know some of the folks that were
nervous about ranked Choice voting in
Maine someone mentioned Bruce Pelican
who was actually the plaintiff in the
federal cases to block ranked Choice
voting in Maine after it was run
what was interesting they had a rematch
this election of Bruce Pollock and the
Republican versus Jared golden the
Democrat and uh also Tiffany Bond who
was ran again as an independent an
interview you know in the news media
interviewed Bruce palkin and just I
guess take his temperature and ranked
Choice voting again I guess they they
weren't sure where he was at after after
the two Federal lawsuits and whatnot so
this time around he said you know what
back in 2018 when we used ranked Choice
voting for the first time you know we
didn't really know what it was about now
we do and we know it's simple so it was
a nice you know as a ranked Choice
voting Advocate that was a really nice
uh testimonial in terms of someone who
had let's say a pretty significant
amount of skepticism initially kind of
kind of come around on the issue
um
so one other thing someone talked to
there was a great discussion about
ranked Choice voting and does it help
more than the two parties or not
um you know if you look at the trends in
Australia so initially both Ireland and
Australia were considered to be pretty
two-party dominant not you know voters
got more choices voters could express
themselves all the benefits folks have
talked about but in terms of ruling it
tended to be one of two parties that's
really started to change in Australia
and in Ireland over the last 20 years
the trend is towards more voters
being inclined to vote for
less you know the parties that haven't
been been in ruling uh for as long so
recently I think uh in in Ireland uh
Shin Fein received a very large vote
share and I don't think they formed a
government but um in in Australia the
percentage received by independent
candidates and by the green party uh
both conservative Independents and more
liberal parties like the green party has
been steadily increasing they're still
not the ruling parties but I guess I
would say I think in general it's not
just Ireland Australia across the world
there's this concept of disaffiliation
where unlike maybe our parents
generation or our parents parents
generation that felt like you know it
was
um I don't know uh
you know but later Miller late or
regular Miller you know one or the other
uh people are interested in having more
choices in today's culture and uh what
we're seeing is the election system
behaves as one would expect and allows
for better expression and better
representation based on those choices
although not doing anything by any means
drastic and last thing us or two more
things real quick
folks have been talking about how ranked
Choice voting combats polarization and
we're having interesting conversation
about the constitutionality and adopting
it for state general elections what was
interesting is because you know Maine
kind of got
there was sort of a compromise in Maine
where because of an advisory opinion
from the main Supreme Court the one
category of Elections Maine did not
adopt for was State offices general
elections but Alaska did and one
interesting thing in the first cycle in
Alaska was you know for the Statewide
races Alaskan voters elected a very
moderate Democrat uh peltola they
elected what was Lisa murkowski who's
considered a moderate Republican and for
governor this is all the same elections
same voters they elected a someone who's
considered to be a Conservative
Republican Governor uh Dunleavy so that
was it was pretty interesting to see the
voter expression and in their Senate
what was interesting in terms of the
decreasing polarization increasing
people working together in government to
get stuff done
the Alaskan senate had a 11 Republicans
and nine Democrats elected the the
majority Coalition that formed was nine
Democrats eight Republicans with a
republican speaker so bipartisan ruling
coalition
I don't know maybe it wouldn't be the
best thing for New Hampshire but imagine
if the political temperature was such
that that was an option in New Hampshire
and people wanted to work together that
closely across the aisle it might be
might be interesting and the very last
thing I will say here is uh you know
Olivia raised a great point about
multi-member districts with ranked
Choice voting and uh and the impact on
voter confidence getting rid of
gerrymandering and Glenn also mentioned
some of the things around stability of
the system those are some really great
benefits I mean you got a really
participatory uh state house in um in
New Hampshire where there's a a
relatively small number of constituents
for each representative which is a great
opportunity
um doing the upgrade to and you have
those multi-member districts which is
Glenn described can produce kind of wild
swings in One Direction or the other
where it's like you elect in all the
Democrats are you electing all the
Republicans depending on how close the
district is or you have some districts
that are consistently one and some
voters just never get their voice heard
in the State House
with the ranked Choice voting the reason
why it gets rid of the gerrymandering
the possibility of gerrymandering is
because what Glenn describes that
proportional way that it gets tabulated
so that
the net result is that
consistently a very high percentage of
Voters
see them elect a candidate that they
really like so in a five-member district
you will consistently see over 83
percent of Voters get a candidate they
like
not in one not just in one District but
across so 83 percent of the Republicans
83 percent of the Democrats electing
someone they like as opposed to right
now it's probably you know it best
closer to 50 percent
uh so everybody feels confidence
gerrymandering's all predicated on
making sure some voters are less able to
elect candidates that represent them and
with this that goes away and as Olivia
said people have more confidence in the
system and as Glenn said because you
know you've got the same district
letting Democrats and Republicans first
of all they now share something in
common they're bringing home the bacon
for their district and number two
um it's much more stable is as opposed
to a district that's going to swing one
way or the other so you're going to have
a state house where it's people's
opinion changes over time it will
gradually reflect that opinion but what
won't happen is you'll have massive
changes in the majority in the State
House based on small changes in you know
how certain voters feel about the issues
so I just want I'll sum up and say that
this is a wonderful opportunity I think
jurisdictions around the country are
showing this is a very feasible reform
to implement and has benefits that can
really benefit
um the people in New Hampshire and and
the people who represent them as well
thank you representative wood would you
grab the blue sheet for this and pass it
up please and now deputy secretary
Lovejoy
thank you Mr chair once again my name is
Patricia Lovejoy I'm the senior deputy
secretary of state
um
just wanted to bring up a few items one
on the Constitutional question we talked
about earlier the plurality versus the
majority of votes that's mentioned in
our constitution three times
if we were to look to really go forward
with ranked Choice voting I think it
would be a good idea to ask the Supreme
Court for an advisory opinion the same
as as what Maine did on that issue
some of the concerns that
um I'd like to bring up
where we do have some towns that have
very large districts when you're looking
at Dairy you have in a general election
you are going to have 20 names on the
ballot so you're going to have 20 names
and going out 10 so ranking those 20
names who's your first choice second
choice third choice
we'll present a more complicated ballot
that's just one of the issues to to keep
in mind
and we have in Dairy is not the only
example of that you have Merrimack has
eight so there would be 60 you know
potential of 16 names
um Bedford has seven so you're at 14
names so there's several uh towns that
that do have that issue
um one thing I also want to point out is
the uh implementation date in this bill
for full the third stage is September of
26 that is not five years from now
that's about three and a half years from
now
um I do not expect that the majority of
our towns will have replaced their
voting machines
um the ballot law commission right now
is looking at different machines we had
one type of machine tested out in a
couple of towns in the November election
there are two possibly three different
um voting tabulators that will be used
in the March elections but we're quite a
ways off from the ballot Mission
deciding what machines will be available
for towns to purchase towns will have to
go through that process probably at
their Town meetings to decide if they
want to change their machines and the
the cost of the machines
people were talking about real world
examples of doing recounts just to give
you an idea of how long it does take if
you are doing a recount and recounts
need to be done by hand
in this last we did recounts for several
weeks this year much more so than we've
done in the past we did Hillsborough
County the entire Hillsborough County
000 ballots we were only looking at One
race and just looking at whether the
Democrat or the Republican got the vote
so no ranked Choice voting it took us
the better half of four days we had
eight teams and if any of you have
watched recounts since recounts are all
public you need to we have teams of two
people doing the counting we have one
you know cameras and monitors
um like I said it it took the better
part of four days to recount 145 000
ballots when we were just looking at
between you know two people
um
and let's see what else did I have on
here
um
I if you you know if you decide you know
looking at these two bills that you want
to do a subcommittee the Secretary of
State's office would be more than
willing to uh to work with you on uh
either or both of these bills
um and I think you know the the other
issues that I talked about last time uh
in the previous bills still exist if
you're going to have ranked Choice
voting
or primaries you really need to consider
the time frame between the primary and
the general election and remember that
we have a 45-day federal
federal requirement that we have to get
our uokova votes out 45 days before the
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you Ms
Lovejoy
um okay
I've been on this committee now this is
my third term we've been talking about
new machines and we actually saw new
machines and every session we're told
they're coming and now it's three and a
half more years is that what I heard you
say
no I said in three this bill the the
full implementation of having all ranked
Choice voting in this bill is three and
a half years
um it was stated earlier it was about
five years but it's three and a half
years
um when when the full ranked choice and
it is the ballot law Commission
that controls what machines can be used
in the state it is not the Secretary of
State's office the legislation gives
that
responsibility to the ballot law
Commission
okay thank you
further questions
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question it sounds like Maine
is able to run elections with ranked
Choice voting
successfully should that example give
this committee confidence that the New
Hampshire Secretary of State's office
could also run elections according to
ranked Choice voting successfully
with different voting machines
our our current voting machines do not
have the um the the capability that we
know of to be able to
um to do this ranked Choice voting I do
believe that if we had different
machines and you are talking about
um that all the results are on a thumb
drive
the our current Courier system I hate
calling the uh our state police couriers
but uh the current system where our
state police bring the the tablets and
the voting the voting results sheet to
the state house if it's just a thumb
drive yes but I do do I believe that we
will be at that point that every town
will have
um upgraded there to a new machine by
September 1st of 2026
you're all from your individual towns
you have a better idea in your
individual town of how fast something
representative Berry off of uh
representative muirhead's question he's
asked is Maine a good example would
maybe a good example
um doesn't it take Maine a week to get
their election results in is that your
understanding
I am not that familiar with Maine's
process and how quickly I mean I know
that they had time to get the uh the
ballots or get the information to the
State House their primaries also in June
for any questions
okay uh blue sheet has eight in favor
three against and that concludes the
so house build 402 is on the house
calendar as an executive session having
not had a public hearing you know that's
not right
and then on these notices of public
hearing because of that confusion and my
being a stickler about proper notices
there will be no hearing on house built
so that leaves us in recess for well
all right
I'll open the executive session on House
Bill 101 representative Berry is
recognized for emotions uh yes Mr
chairman I move that uh House Bill 101
be inexpedient to legislate
representative Berry would you like to
speak to your motion uh briefly
um uh hb101 removes the ability for
unaffiliated voters to cast a ballot in
a partisan primary I don't need to go
into the details of the committee about
how that's technically not true but one
of the things that's in the RSA is the
political parties now have the ability
to choose if they want to allow
unaffiliated voters or not so the bill
will be effectively removing that choice
there's no point in doing that if either
political party thought this was a good
idea they could hardly implement it so
why take it away from them
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
the motion is in expedient to legislate
on House Bill won't open oh I'm sorry
yeah
that was done representative the motion
um the bill is HP 101 with a fiscal note
the motion is itl um I'll now report the
role
um Ross Berry Vice chair
representative uh prudhome O'Brien yes
representative qualey yes
representative Ann kerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes
representative wood
yes
representative Lane ranking member
representative Ward
representative Hamer
representative Hamlet yes
representative Bay
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill representative girl
votes yes
and representative Howard
yes
that is
oh chairman Smith
yes
at that point you need me to make it you
know
that is um 19 years zero Nays zero
non-voting
somebody want to move consent I'll move
that to consent calendar any objection
to consent are we not allowed to have
consent calendar for a fiscal note
okay thank you so this bill will go on
consent
and Mr chairman I'll be doing the
committee report
thank you
and today right yes
I already gave the committee
um you may not go home I put a boot on
your wheel until I got the committee
report that'd be you and the City of
Concord
open the executive session on House Bill
116 representative Ankerberg is
recognized for a motion thank you Mr
chairman move
we retain House Bill 116 FM
is there a second
I'll second that
just like to speak to emotion
thank you Mr chair the sponsor has
indicated he'd like an opportunity to
work on the language and I guess we're
going to Grant him
thank you further discussion on the bill
and for the committee's information what
retained means is we probably have to
report on it out on it by November 1st
if the sponsor comes forward with
information and does work we will meet
between now and then to consider that if
he doesn't I don't call a meeting and we
any other discussion
all right the clerk will call the roll
the bill is HP 116 with a fiscal note
the motion is retained I'll Now read the
role
um Vice chair Barry yay
representative prudhom O'Brien yes
representative boom yeah
representative quaily yes representative
Ankerberg
yes
representative Burnham
yes representative Kennedy
representative weary
uh ranking member Elaine
yes
representative Ward
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Bay
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl representative girl
votes yes representative Howard
yes
and chairman Smith yes
and once again that is 19 years and zero
Nays and zero non-voting um the motion
passes
we're gonna chain bills do not have a
committee report so that isn't necessary
and it doesn't go on the calendar for
the house to vote on it's the bill is
now still in our possession
so that'll close the executive session
on House Bill 116. a couple quick notes
before we go
I was asked a really good question
earlier today so I couldn't make it this
morning representative Berry was here he
opened it what if he wasn't here then
representative Bohm will open it what
happens if representative Smith Berry
and Bohm
are not here this means that the world
has ended and you don't have to worry
about the hearing
yeah
but um no seriously what would happen is
representative barrier I would have
contacted the speaker's office to make
sure that
somebody came over here at the appointed
time during whatever Calamity occurred
um procedure on Executive sessions I
have no idea why I wrote that down in my
notes so we'll skip it
but anyway so that's what happens
first bill that we're sending to the
calendar is on Con on consent that makes
me happy thank you you're free to go